merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre à la lassitude que nous
ressentons tous après deux ans de crise
sanitaire ne peuvent s'ajouter
l'impréparation et les incohérences nous
sommes les premiers à reconnaître que
c'est compliqué et qu'il n'ya sans doute
pas qu'une seule bonne réponse mais
parce que c'est compliqué il faut de la
méthode que dire monsieur le premier
ministre du ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui annonce par voie de presse
un dimanche soir le nouveau protocole
pour la rentrée le lundi suivant que
dire du ministre de la santé qui affirme
le 16 décembre je le cite que nous
freinons le variant au micro avec succès
fermez les guillemets et qui après une
semaine lance en urgence le pass
vaccinale mon groupe monsieur le premier
ministre est le seul à avoir prôné dès
juillet dernier la vaccination
obligatoire pour tous les adultes c'est
une règle simple applicable à tous et
qui aurait permis un suivi par les
caisses primaires d'assurance maladie
notamment en direction des personnes les
moins informés et qu'ils ne sont pas
forcément contre la vaccination pourquoi
ne l'avez vous pas reprises pourquoi lui
avoir préféré le pass vaccinale qui
reporte sur d'autres la responsabilité
qui vous incombent il reste 5 millions
de français vaccinés et l'annoncent du
post vaccinales n'a pas créé
d'engouement pour les premières doses
avec les modalités que vous avez prévu
vous mettez les jeunes de 12 à 15 ans
dans une impasse si leurs parents
refusent le vaccin pour eux ils n'auront
pas de passes vaccinale ainsi ils ne
pourront plus pratiquer ni le sport ni
les loisirs auquel le pass sanitaire
l'ordonné droit jusqu alors monsieur le
premier ministre je vous demande de ne
pas appliquer le pass vaccinale aux
mineurs de 12 à 15 ans c'est le sens de
notre un moment 645 soutenue par de
nombreux groupes
merci madame la présidente
la parole est à baisser le premier
ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la
présidente valérie rabault d'abord
permettez mon nom du gouvernement de
m'associer aux voeux de prompt
rétablissement que vous avez adressé
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de l'assemblée nationale
cher président valérie rabault
il y a
quelques jours avant noël
j'ai comme je le fais de très multiples
reprises convoqué le comité de liaison
réunissant l'ensemble des présidents de
groupes parlementaires
pour sceller la concertation à laquelle
je suis profondément attachée comme vous
pour faire part d'une part de
l'évolution extrêmement rapide de la
situation sanitaire en france comme dans
les pays d'europe et pour vous indiquer
les mesures que le gouvernement
entendait prendre et recueillir les
propositions des groupes il me semble me
souvenir cher présidente que lorsque
pour les raisons que j'ai d'ailleurs
exposé devant la nation j'ai proposé que
nous passions du pass sanitaire au pass
vaccinale
vous avez indiqué que votre groupe il
serait favorable
bien ce n'est pas tout à fait ce que
j'ai cru comprendre au cheikh présidente
de votre question pour ceux là pour cela
madame la présidente faut-il que le
débat s'organise la situation du pays je
le dis solennellement devant la
représentation nationale est difficile
le taux d'incidence des passes 1800 hier
près de vingt mille personnes étaient
hospitalisées pour cause de qu'ovide
hier
272 de nos concitoyens sont morts du
fait de la maladie portant le nombre de
décès depuis son déclenchement à 124
1247 et pendant ce temps là je le dis me
tournant vers cette partie de
l'hémicycle
certains s'ingénient à faire des coups
politiques pour aider le débat
je vous le dis je vous le dis ce n'est
pas responsable
ce n'est pas responsable
oui madame la présidente pour le coup
vous avez raison nous sommes engagés
dans une course contre la montre
le virus le virus galope et vous tirez
sur les frères amer
que passe selon un citoyen de ses
facéties
croyez-vous qu'il reçu le débat public
albas coppens et mesdames et messieurs
les députés nos soignants engagé qui eux
ne s'arrête pas à minuit quand vous
l'avez souhaité voter
c'est pure bâti responsable
j'appelle j'appelle
la représentation nationale
à la sérénité qu'exigent les
circonstances mesdames et messieurs les
députés
j'appelle l'assemblée nationale et je
vous remercie madame la présidente je le
dis ici de la position de votre groupe
qui a accepté de renoncer ou de décaler
son temps de débats pour permettre la
discussion sur ce très important projet
de loin de reprendre sans délai et je
regrette l est républicain n'est pas eu
le même sens des responsabilités
je ne comprend pas davantage
fait le propre des avantages monsieur le
président mais qu'après qu'un certain
nombre de responsables de votre parti de
manière très responsable se soient
prononcés pour le post vaccinales hier
soir 32 députés aient voté contre il
faut remettre de la sérénité et de
l'ordre je vous remercie
merci monsieur pas m'y attendais madame
madame la présidente je vous donne ma
parole vous avez effectivement du temps
chers collègues mes chers collègues on
ne prend tous ses engagements en début
de séance on prend tous les engagements
de sérénité de respect 1 on n'a pas dès
la première question un compte revenir à
nos engagements alors nous on va écouter
sereinement madame la présidente rabot à
qui il reste quinze secondes merci
monsieur le premier ministre le premier
ministre ce que apple écoutez mais ces
premiers ni je vous parle pas de coup
politique je vous parle de cohérence il
ya des enfants de 12 à 15 ans dont les
parents ne vont pas vouloir qu'ils
soient vaccinés demain ils ne peuvent
plus faire ni sport ni loisir qu'est ce
que vous dites à ces jeunes de 12 à 15
ans monsieur le premier ministre
merci madame la présidente
nous allons écouter maintenant le
président andré chassaigne président du
groupe gdr
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre depuis le
début de l'année 3 féminicide ont eu
lieu dans notre pays trois femmes ont
été tuées par leur compagnon ou
ex-compagnon trois femmes que la société
n'a pas pu n'a pas su protéger l'année
dernière ce sont 113 femmes qui ont été
tués les chiffres sont terribles il se
répète d'année en année sans compter les
victimes collatérales de ces violences
que sont les enfants si sur le plan
législatif il y a eu des avancées les
moyens mis en place pour l'application
de ces lois restent pour autant
nettement insuffisant par rapport à
l'ampleur du phénomène qui traversent la
société toute entière
c'est ce que nous disent les
associations des collectifs féministes
les crédits sont sous dimensionnés il
faut un milliard consacré spécifiquement
à la lutte contre les violences faites
aux femmes de plus il est impératif de
former tous les personnels susceptibles
d'accueillir et d'accompagner les femmes
victimes de mettre en place les mesures
d'éloignement et de les faire respecter
ces violences sont systématiques elle
appelle donc des réponses globales à la
hauteur des drames nous devons assurer
un suivi complet des victimes juridiques
médicales sociales raccourcir au maximum
tous les délais déployer l'ensemble des
dispositifs dont nous disposons comme
les bracelets anti rapprochement qui
sont seulement quelques centaines pour
plus de deux cent mille victimes
monsieur le premier ministre il est
temps il est temps d'en finir avec le
saupoudrage de petites mesures à chaque
drame quelle réponse globale
structurelles massive allez-vous
apporter aux femmes de notre pays pour
qu'elles puissent enfin enfin vivre dans
une société libérée du patriarcat et qui
les protègent de la violence merci
monsieur le président le sait le premier
ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs député monsieur le
président andré chassaigne encore un
sujet extrêmement grave qui fait l'objet
de votre question est qui va me
permettre je pense vous donner des
éléments démontrant le total engagement
du gouvernement et de la nation face à
ce fléau vous avez raison de le rappeler
je le redis devant la représentation
nationale plus de 100 féminicide ont été
déplorés au cours de l'année 2000 21 qui
vient de s'achever et déjà depuis le
début de la nouvelle nous déplorons
trois nouveaux meurtres dans des
conditions tout à fait scandaleuse et
j'ai avec vous une pensée pour les
victimes et pour leurs familles c'est un
grand combat assurément vous l'avez dit
monsieur le président qui doit tous nous
mobiliser avec lisabeth moreno avec le
garde des sceaux le ministre d'intérieur
l'ensemble du gouvernement c'est ce que
nous faisons vous le savez nous avons
adopté cette majorité a adopté un
grenelle des violences conjugales en
2019 y avait 48 mesure je les ai
compléter de manière significative après
les drames de mérignac et dayan et je
suis en mesure de vous donner les faits
précis suivant d'abord le budget cher
président et nous vous le détailleront
le milliard d'euros que vous appelez de
vos voeux est d'ores et déjà atteint au
service de la lutte contre les violences
conjugales
le 39 19 que vous avez souvent cité pour
que les femmes puissent appeler au
secours est désormais depuis quelques
mois actif 24 heures sur 24 365 jours
par an les places d'hébergement parce
qu'il faut sortir très vite les femmes
de la situation de détresse dans
laquelle elle se trouve plus 1000 en
2020 +1000 en 2021 +1000 supplémentaires
seront créés en 2022 portant à la fin de
l'année à 9 villes le nombre de places
d'hébergement nous avons par ailleurs
multiplié par trois l'accès des femmes
en danger aux logements sociaux
90000 vous évoquer la question cher
président de la formation 90 mille
policiers et gendarmes sont désormais
formée notamment pour recevoir des
plaintes des plantes qu'on peut prendre
désormais dans 215 établissements de
santé et nous expérimentons dans un
certain nombre de départements les
plaintes hors les murs le téléphone
grave danger il y en a trois mille
aujourd'hui est notre objectif de 5000 à
la fin de l'année prochaine devrait être
atteint les bracelets en tirant
franchement vous les avez évoqué mille
sont disponibles nous sommes maintenant
quasiment au chiffre de l'espagne qui a
souvent été citée ici dans cet hémicycle
1 un exemple enfin sur le champ de la
prévention je voudrais citer la décision
prise par monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale à la demande des
associations que nous soutenons et
auquel vous avez fait allusion une
semaine de l'égalité à l'école des
filles et des garçons pour traiter
expliqué les questions de violence
conjugale sera à partir de l'année
prochaine organisé chaque 8 mars c'est
un sujet très important nous le prenons
très au sérieux
merci monsieur le pen unis
la parole est un monsieur pascal bois
monsieur le président
merci mes chers collègues mon propos
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
suite aux innombrables menaces et actes
de violence commis à l'égard d'élus
locaux et de représentants de la nation
dont votre serviteur jusqu'à son
domicile familial dans un contexte tendu
par l'examen du passé vaccinale que par
ailleurs je soutiens nous subissons
directement des actes de violence ces
actes ces menaces aux prédictions
macabre je sais que bon nombre de
collègues ici présents ont déjà eu à les
subir ils sont inacceptables en
démocratie il y a toujours d'autres
moyens d'expression à commencer par
celle des urnes dont on doit respecter
les résultats et nous disposons tous
deux permanences vous recevoir et
écouter nos concitoyens
toutefois il n'en demeure pas moins que
certains de ces actes sont criminels et
la vitalité de notre démocratie ne
saurait s'en accommoder le silence radio
assourdissant de certains responsables
politiques participent à cette
banalisation
cela me peine et ce qui nous arrive que
nous arriver à tous en revanche monsieur
le premier ministre c'est des faits ne
sont pas le fruit du hasard ils sont la
résultante de manipulation encouragés
par des discours autour outrancier les
auteurs de ces actes lâches ne
respectent pas les libertés qu'ils
prétendent défendre
pas plus que ceux qui les inspirent ou
limotive à commettre l'irréparable dans
un sentiment d'impunité
hier contre le masque la vaccination le
pass annie terre enfin contre le pass
vaccinale tout n'est que prétexte pour
s'opposer aux consignes sanitaires sans
aucune alternative or nous vivons dans
un état de droit qui prend soin du plus
grand nombre face à tout cela il faut
savoir rester digne et porter haut nos
valeurs communes et notre bien le plus
précieux la démocratie
monsieur le premier ministre je sais
combien cette crise sanitaire concentre
toutes les attentions mais il faut
collectivement dénoncé ces actes lutter
inlassablement contre les mensonges et
s'obliger à la nuance dans nos propos
pour apaiser la situation dans les
débats puis dans le reste de la société
vous remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs et député dechert député
pascal bois je vous remercie de votre
question à laquelle j'ai souhaité
répondre moi-même après avoir échangé
avec vous il y a quelques semaines
puisque vous avez chacun le sait et c
était la cible de violences sur votre
domicile qui sont parfaitement
inacceptables et je voudrais aux marques
de solidarité dont je vous ai témoigné
au nom du gouvernement associer tous les
parlementaires de tous les bords tous
les élus de la république quel qu'il
soit qui à un titre ou un autre ont été
menacés dans l'accomplissement de leurs
fonctions
vous avez raison
c'est un sujet où nous touchons
l'essentiel toute violence et bien
entendu inacceptable toute violence est
inacceptable dans une société
démocratique et je constate avec vous
bien sûr la montée des phénomènes de
violence sous toutes leurs formes qu'il
nous faut combattre mais s'agissant de
dépositaire de l'autorité publique de
dépositaire du suffrage universel
alors le recours à la violence vous
l'avez dit monsieur le député c'est la
démocratie c'est le pacte républicain
qu'elle vient menacer pour ce faire au
delà évidemment de la solidarité de la
protection que nous vous devons et je
signale à la représentation nationale
qu'encore une fois à la fin d'année
dernière le ministre de l'intérieur à
redemander à chacun des préfets de
département de veiller à la protection
rapprochée si nécessaire des élus de la
nation nous avons durci vous avez cette
majorité je vous le rappelle a durci la
réglementation pour punir parce qu'il
n'y a pas d'autre voie que la répression
face à ces actes ignobles dois je vous
rappeler mesdames et messieurs les
députés la loi du 24 août dernier qui
créent
le délit de mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui avec des peines aggravées si
les faits sont commis à l'encontre d'un
élu cinq ans d'emprisonnement dois-je
rappeler la loi pour la confiance dans
l'institution judiciaire toute récente
qui a supprimé les crédits de réduction
de peine automatiques et durci les
conditions d'octroi des réductions de
peine en cas de condamnation à des faits
de violence contre les élus et d'autre
part supprimé le rappel à la loi
applicable dès sa publication en cas de
délits commis contre un élu dois je vous
rappeler la circulaire que le garde des
sceaux a pris à ma demande dès septembre
2020 pour demander aux procureurs
généraux au procureur de la république
une des réponses pénales systématiques
ferme et rapide avec suivi judiciaire
renforcé au delà le ceat monsieur le
député comme vous l'avez fait je
voudrais vous dire combien je suis
touché par le fait qu'en dépit de ces
menaces vous le leur seuil est en rien
vous continuer en toute circonstance
d'exercer votre beau mandat de
parlementaire faisant plus que jamais
honneur à la république
merci
la parole est à monsieur pierre vatin
merci monsieur le président avant tout
monsieur le premier ministre vous
permettez je note que les députés de la
majorité se lèvent aujourd'hui pour vous
applaudir alors qu'hier soir il était
déjà couché
c'est malheureusement
c'est c'est malheureusement
l'amateurisme et la démobilisation que
l'on a vu à l'oeuvre hier
[Applaudissements]
bon allez ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la santé
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la santé eh oui
et aucune train
monsieur le député alé di
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la santé
monsieur le ministre
votre arrogance et votre auto
satisfaction permanent le suffisent à
lévis à lévis le député c'est ridicule
c'est ridicule je le dis aux uns et aux
autres voilà que ce matin vous avez la
parole
[Applaudissements]
la question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la santé
votre auto satisfaction permanente ne
suffit plus à masquer vos propres
errements dans la gestion de la crise
c'est simple vous avez toujours raison
l'autre jour vous me dites que l'hôpital
de compiègne est mal gérée sans jamais
vous mettre vous même face à vos
responsabilités
or vous nous promettez dix mille lits
d'hôpitaux supplémentaires pendant la
crise non seulement ces lignes n'ont pas
été ouverts mais vous en avez même fermé
et tous les hôpitaux des programmes des
opérations faute d'infirmières
d'aides-soignantes en nombre suffisant
mais sur cette déprogrammation on ne
vous entend jamais sur le terrain des
équipes font un travail remarquable mais
les recrutements ne suivent pas vous
dites que le ségur de la santé le remède
à tous les maux des hôpitaux or il
n'évite pas les déprogrammations et il
ne crée pas d'infirmières
supplémentaires
monsieur le ministre je ne peux que
regretter l'absence de vision du
gouvernement et votre absence
d'anticipation en ce domaine celle des
programmations sont un terrible aveu
d'impuissance elles ont de très lourdes
conséquences sur les patients voilà deux
ans que la crise du co lead à toucher
les français et depuis le début nous
avions réclamé la formation de personnel
supplémentaire en urgence ces nouveaux
étudiants infirmiers serait quasi
opérationnel aujourd'hui mais où sont
ils merci monsieur
la parole est à monsieur le ministre de
l'aider solidarité et de la santé
monsieur verra
messieurs mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur débuté vatin vous avez
raison la déprogrammation est un
phénomène que nous devrions éviter à
chaque fois qu'un français par ses soins
des programmes est c'est pour pouvoir
hospitalisé en urgence un patient non
vaccinés
j'aurais eu à coeur monsieur le député
vous étiez présent en moi aussi de
pouvoir débattre jusqu'au bout de la
nuit de la manière dont nous pouvions
protéger mieux notre population réduire
ainsi le taux de transfert non encore
vaccinés et ainsi éviter à nos soignants
le pénible exercice quotidien de se
réunir de façon collégiale pour savoir
qui aujourd'hui ne serait pas opéré et
qui ne pourraient pas être soigné pour
accueillir des patients non vaccinés
joignez donc votre vote aux principes
que vous voulez soutenir monsieur débuté
il n'est jamais trop tard
2e deuxième élément vous parlez des
capacités hospitalières de réanimation
j'ai bien entendu madame valérie
pécresse hier matin en matinale qui
expliquait que hélas le numerus clausus
pendant dix ans avait fait des ravages
je suis obligé de répéter ce que j'ai
déjà dit dans l'hémicycle les
réanimateurs qui sont diplômés
aujourd'hui et qui sortent de l'internât
sont les réanimateurs qui étaient les
étudiants en médecine entre 2007 et 2011
en première année quand votre candidate
mme pécresse était ministre en charge du
numerus clausus
ce qui veut dire mathématiquement
monsieur matin que si lorsque l'été
ministre en responsabilité elle avait
décidé de faire ce que nous avons fait
cette majorité a voté supprimer
l'humérus juge dès 2018 il y aurait
aujourd'hui quinze mille médecins de
plus dans le territoire toutes vos
questions sur les déserts médicaux
toutes vos questions sur les
déprogrammations toutes vos questions
sur le nombre de réanimateurs etc j'ai
envie de vous les renvoyer monsieur le
député vous êtes en train de faire le
bilan de votre propre mandature passée
est devenue la candidate veut soutenir
merci
merci monsieur munich la parole est à
madame jennifer de temmerman
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale
être au plus près de la réalité c'est
par ces mots monsieur le ministre vous
justifier d'avoir transmis le protocole
sanitaire
via la presse payante aux enseignants à
quelques heures de la rentrée mais
monsieur le ministre connaissez-vous la
réalité des établissements scolaires
j'ai été enseignante et personnels de
direction s'imaginer que transmettent
les protocoles au recteur le dimanche en
fin d'après-midi permettrait une rentrée
sereine et organisée
c'est méconnaître profondément la
réalité des personnels que vous avez
sous votre tutelle agir de la sorte à la
veille d'une rentrée scolaire et plus
particulièrement après les fêtes de fin
d'année c'est ajouter de la confusion a
ajouté du stress à des situation déjà
difficile
aujourd'hui nos enseignants vont mal nos
enfants vont mal et les parents sont
perdus être conscient de la réalité
s'est donné les moyens au personnel de
s'organiser bien en amont de la rentrée
plutôt que de leur transmettre une
avalanche de consignes à mettre en place
par des canaux non officielle s'est
concerté avec eux et avec les
collectivités plutôt que de laisser les
personnels gérer seul les absences des
enseignants et des élèves et les
inquiétudes des parents être au plus
près de la réalité c'est protéger les
enseignants les élèves en leur
fournissant des masques ffp2 plutôt qu
en tissu s'est débloqué des fonds et
accompagner les collectivités pour
équiper les établissements de capteur de
co2 et de purificateurs d'air nous avons
attiré votre attention à de nombreuses
reprises en vain sur ces enjeux cruciaux
quand allez-vous mettre en place des
mesures pratiques et concrètes au lieu
de poudre aux yeux quand allez vous
revenir à la réalité
au l'état monsieur jean michel blanquer
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse et des sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
jennifer de temmerman la question de la
rentrée scolaire étaient évidemment une
question clé pour cette nouvelle année
et il était très important de prévenir
le plus possible en a en amont les
personnels on est bien d'accord sur ce
point c'est pourquoi les informations
principales ont été donnés à la suite du
conseil de défense la semaine dernière
lorsque nous avons réaffirmé que le
protocole de s'appliquer dans le second
degré le protocole iii dans le premier
degré j'ai été amené à même j'ai été
amené à dire aussi publiquement mardi
dernier que c'était sur le sujet dès
tests qu'il y aurait une évolution
majeure nous avons ensuite eu un
processus que vous connaissez c'est à
dire la consultation de la haute
autorité de santé publique qui s'est
prononcée le 31 décembre au soir nous
avons travaillé le 1er janvier et
ensuite comme prévu le 2 janvier 2010 de
la santé s'est exprimé pour avoir la
doctrine générale pour qu'elle ait une
cohérence entre ce qui se passe à
l'éducation nationale et dans le reste
de la société et ensuite je me suis
exprimé contrairement à ce que vous avez
dit ce qui est passé en communication
interne au personnel est arrivé un peu
avant la publication dans un média il y
avait d'ailleurs beaucoup plus
d'informations sur le site du ministère
que dans ce journal quand je sais que
quelque chose qu'on répète fini par être
une sorte de vérité admise mais la
réalité celle que je viens de vous dire
j'en profite pour le dire à tous
d'ailleurs ce qu'on appelle la foire aux
questions c'est à dire la réponse aux
questions concrètes qui se pose est
actualisée en permanence sur le site du
ministère évidemment disponibles
notamment pour tous les personnels
donc oui madame la députée notre but est
d'être au plus près du terrain je sais
que certains cherchent à faire des
polémiques j'ai l'impression que vous en
faites partie mais ce qui est important
c'est que nous avons réussi à avoir les
écoles ouvertes et si je suis devant
recommandations à chaque fois je ne
crois pas que les écoles seraient
ouverts dans le pays autant qu'elles ont
été je vous remercie
madame la députée monsieur le mini je ne
fais pas de politique je suis une
professionnelle de l'éducation nationale
et les témoignages que je reçois de mes
collègues en poste contredisent tous ce
que vous affirmez si quelqu'un veut d'un
coup politique c'est bien vous et vous
n'écoutez rien vous préférez vous
présente en dhr parler dans les médias
merci
monsieur le ministre
la madame la députée il me semblait que
vous étiez surtout députés en ce moment
mais merci de confirmer aussi le
jugement que je portais c'est à dire
vous chercher la polémique pendant ce
temps là nous travaillons c'est
difficile pour tout le monde pour tous
les personnels merci au personnel je
vous remercie
la parole est à m que jean-marie fievet
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre qui associe à ma question mes
collègues marie silin et
pierre-alexandre anglade la france a
depuis le 1er janvier la présidence du
conseil de l'union européenne pour une
période de six mois c'est une immense
fierté une grande responsabilité pour
notre pays et pour tous les européens
ce moment si particulier qui survient
seulement une fois tous les 13 de 13 ans
doit permettre de réaffirmer haut et
fort les valeurs démocratiques dans
notre union comme le respect de l'état
de droit l'égalité la liberté et les
droits de l'homme
c'est ce socle solide qui nous a permis
de bâtir une europe de la paix et que
nous permettra demain de bâtir une
europe plus solidaire et plus forte face
au fracas du monde
soyons donc fier du bleu européen
symbole de paix qui illumine nos
monuments
soyons fiers de notre drapeau européen
partout ils se hissent y compris à l'arc
de triomphe
nous n'avons aucune leçon de patriotisme
à recevoir de ceux qui méconnaissent et
fondements mêmes de notre belle
république la france est un grand pays
européen et elle le prouvera tout au
long de cette présidence
c'est de l' occasion unique de mettre en
oeuvre les grandes ambitions européennes
portées par notre pays en matière de
transition écologique de politique
d'asile mais également de souveraineté
européenne et de construction d'une
europe de la défense
cette dernière nécessite et nécessite
une réelle impulsion franche et
ambitieuse grâce au concours des états
membres et deux industries la france
sera soutenir cet objectif monsieur le
ministre
pouvez vous nous préciser les grands
chantiers de la présidence française de
l'union et le calendrier qui marquera ce
moment que si cruciale je vous remercie
l'asim ses députés la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères monsieur jean yves
le drian oui monsieur le député
jean-marie fievel et les principaux
temps forts de la présidence française
vont avoir lieu dès les prochains jours
puisque le collège des commissaires va
être reçu à paris cette semaine dans un
respect extrêmement strictes du
protocole sanitaire et que se tiendra se
tiendront la semaine prochaine deux
réunions informelles à bresse des
ministres de la défense et des ministres
des affaires étrangères ce sera un
moment très important puisque nous avons
souhaité à la demande du président de la
république
l'europe plus souveraine soit une de nos
priorités de cette présidence
une europe plus souveraine ça veut dire
une europe capable de maîtriser ses
frontières ça veut dire aussi une europe
qui renforce sa politique de défense
comme vous l'avez souligné et nous
aurons je pense l'opportunité d'endosser
ce qu'on appelle la boussole
stratégiques c'est-à-dire en fait un
livre blanc sur la défense européenne
que nous allons sur lequel nous allons
travailler à brest concomitamment avec
madame la ministre dès désarmés et puis
c'est aussi une europe plus souveraine
c'est une europe qui assure la stabilité
et la prospérité de son voisinage nous
aurons l'occasion de le faire au moment
des crises et singulièrement dans
l'appréhension de la crise ukrainienne
où l'europe doit faire entendre sa voix
et ses intérêts et puis le point d'orgue
sera à cet égard le sommet entre l'union
africaine et l'union européenne au mois
de février prochain puis plus tard la
conférence sur les balkans dans que la
souveraineté de l'union européenne et
puis aussi la définition d'un nouveau
modèle de croissance que qui doit
aboutir logiquement un sommet au mois de
mars de projeter sur l'europe 2030 et
nous aurons à coeur clément bonne et moi
même de faire avancer au cours de cette
présidence des textes qui contribue à
l'élaboration de notre nouveau modèle
européen que ce soit le mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone que ce soit la
régulation du numérique que ce soit le
salaire minimum que ce soit l'égalité
homme-femme et puis enfin il y aura un
point final d'une certaine manière avec
la conférence sur l'avenir de l'europe
qui renforcera j'en suis sûr à la fois
la volonté de préserver nos valeurs mais
aussi depuis le renforcement et la
protection de l'état de droit merci
la parole est un monsieur michel vialay
monsieur le premier ministre sous
l'effet du variant au micron les
chiffres des contaminations atteignent
des sommets encore jamais atteint nos
hôpitaux sont dans une situation très
grave de saturation et je ne reviens pas
sur votre responsabilité quant à la
fermeture de lits et la pénurie de
personnel que vient d'évoquer notre
collègue pierre vatin dans ce contexte
il ne suffit pas que votre ministre de
la santé affiche une autosatisfaction
péremptoire avec le manque d'humilité
qui le caractérise pour que vos
décisions soient pertinentes surtout
dans ce contexte il est indécent que
votre mini de l'éducation nationale
annonce la veille de la rentrée à 17
heures de nouvelles dispositions qui
s'appliquent dès lendemain matin sans
anticipation notamment s'il ya un cas
positif dans une classe tous les élèves
doivent être testés trois fois dans les
quatre jours mais il ya une pénurie de
test comment on fait
actif puisque la devise qui encadre la
présidence comprend le mot appartenance
cette appartenance au projet européen
passe aussi par des symboles le drapeau
européen déployés sous l'arc de triomphe
était un geste symboliquement fort n'en
déplaise aux oppositions la conviction
européenne ne s'oppose pas au
patriotisme
elles complètent ce soit pour les
soldats tombés que nous avons décrété
plus jamais ce sont pour eux que le
projet européen est née une réponse aux
sacrifices consentis aussi monsieur le
ministre pourriez vous nous préciser les
différentes manifestations qui auront
lieu sur le volet appartenance de la
présidence française de l'ue au et
comment les parlementaires ils seront
associés merci la parole est un monsieur
clément bonne ce qu est l etat chargé
des affaires européennes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la
présidente sabine thilay vous avez
raison de revenir sur les enjeux
fondamentaux de cette présidence et vous
avez je crois raison aussi de souligner
cela n'est pas contradictoire cela n'est
pas anecdotique
nous avons besoin de symboles de les
assumer et je crois de les partager nous
avons en effet pavoiser un certain
nombre de monuments publics dont l'arc
de triomphe aux couleurs de l'europe
pour marquer le début de cette
présidence je veux d'ailleurs dans un
esprit républicain d'unité qui devrait
nous anime et saluer l'ensemble des
parlementaires sur tous les bancs qui
n'ont pas emboîté le pas des polémiques
stériles y compris dans le camp de
monsieur ciotti madame pécresse je les
en remercie
je veux saluer les maires plus nombreux
encore qui comme jamais en france ont
pavoisé les monuments publics leur
mairie toutes sensibilités politiques
confondues dans toute la france parce
qu'ils n'ont pas l'europe honteuse et je
crois qu'aucun d'entre nous devraient
l'avoir cas nous devrions être fiers de
porter les idées françaises en europe
pendant ce semestre alors nous
continuerons n'en déplaise à ceux qui
confondent élan patriotique avec le
petit commerce électoral et nous
avancerons sur le fond des priorités de
cette présidence jean yves le drian les
a rappelés sur le climat sur la question
numérique sur la protection de notre
sécurité c'est cela être à la hauteur
des enjeux nous le ferons aussi sur les
questions culturelles madame la
présidente vous avez raison le prénom de
la république l'a annoncé avec sarah
lane nous porterons la question du
service civique européen pour donner
l'expérience concrète à tous les jeunes
c'est une formidable réussite
nous défendrons aussi nos valeurs la
liberté de la presse la liberté de la
justice la liberté et droits
fondamentaux en europe qui sont parfois
menacées nous aurons l'occasion à
travers la conférence sur l'avenir de
l'europe qui sera conclu au mois de mai
sous présidence française de l'union
européenne de porter ces valeurs de
porter ces engagements dans être fiers
ensemble car nous n'avons pas honte
d'être fiers nous n'avons pas honte
d'être français en europe
la parole est à monsieur maxime minot
113-113 femme tuée sous les coups de
leur compagnon de leur ex compagnon en
2021 3 féminicide en trois jours en 2022
insupportable chiffres qui révèlent de
terribles drames contre lesquels notre
groupe est historiquement mobilisés mais
surtout force de proposition comme
l'illustrent notamment le débat que nous
aurons ce soir dans cet hémicycle sur ce
sujet à notre initiative quoi que vous
en pensiez monsieur le premier ministre
surtout l'adoption à l'unanimité de
notre texte du texte de notre collègue
d'aurélien pradié et pour ne pas
rajouter de déshonneur de la république
à l'horreur
lorsque trop de lois votées ne sont pas
suivies d'effet réel nous avons dès le
lendemain du vote de la loi vérifier son
application sur le terrain qu'en est-il
seulement deux cent cinquante bracelets
anti-rapprochement prononcer monsieur le
premier ministre je vous le dis droit
dans les yeux je vous ai trouvé un digne
il ya quelques minutes car c'est à
l'honneur des députés aient l'air
d'avoir inscrit à l'ordre du jour de
l'hémicycle un débat sur ce sujet pour
réclamer une mobilisation générale sur
les violences conjugales
et non monsieur le premier ministre nous
allons pas sacrifier cette cause et
renoncer à ce débat car pour nous les
violences conjugales sont tout aussi
importantes que le pass vaccinale alors
monsieur le premier ministre les mots ne
suffisent plus face à la détresse de
toutes ces femmes les avancées
législatives et les efforts de tous les
acteurs mobilisés ne seront fécond que
le jour où il existera une justice qui
dispose de moyens nécessaires pour
prévenir et lutter efficacement contre
ces violences car si le sujet des
violences conjugales n'a jamais été
aussi présent dans le débat public il
faut aller plus loin plus fort et aller
plus vite pour nous la priorité est de
changer cette réalité terrible à
laquelle nous n'avons pas le droit de
nous habituer à nos yeux la france est
un grand pays qui doit mobiliser toutes
ses forces pour venir à bout d'un si
grand fléau restaurer la france et la
faire rayonner passera par ce grand
combat pour les droits des femmes alors
monsieur le premier ministre que temps
perdu quand allez vous passer de la
parole aux actes
merci monsieur le député
la parole est à monsieur eric
dupond-moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
[Applaudissements]
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député minots je
connais votre sagesse
et votre sens de la nuance désormais
légendaire et je ne peux pas imaginer
une seconde que la question que vous
venez de nous poser serait
l'instrumentalisation de ces meurtres
qui nous terrifie tous en réalité mais
mais mais je note monsieur le député
minot que vos propos font écho à une
offensive lancée dans le journal le
monde par madame pécresse votre
championne est l'un de ses porte parole
en clair il est exprimé que nous
n'aurions rien fait mais que vous ferez
tout alors on va s'arrêter une toute
petite seconde parce que voyez vous dans
ce domaine monsieur minots il faut être
plein d'humilité et je vais vous
rappeler ce que votre
championne a fait lorsqu'elle était aux
manettes je vais vous rappeler réfusé
mans précisément les chiffres écoutez
monsieur minot madame pécresse c'est le
dernier quinquennat de votre famille
politique
2007 2012
168 féminicide en 2008 où étiez vous
monsieur minot
151 féminicide en 2009 où étiez vous
157 féminicide en 2010 je vous le
demande où était votre famille politique
et 166 féminicide en 2012 mais qu'avez
vous fait quant à la loi pradier elle a
été votée aussi ne l'oublié pas grâce à
notre majorité et c'est nous qui l'avons
mise en oeuvre j'aurai le plaisir ce
soir dans un débat qui n'a pas été
supprimée c'est un mensonge mais décalée
de vous dire et je resterai s'il le faut
jusqu'à 5 heures du matin
quel est le bilan de notre gouvernement
mais quelquefois lamssirine
trimestielles ministre d'apporter
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
monsieur minot pour six secondes
monsieur le ministre tant qu'il restera
une seule femme une seule et dernière
femmes victimes de violences conjugales
elle sera nous le nous serons à ses
côtés merci monsieur le député la parole
est à monsieur guillaume garot
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la santé je veux une
nouvelle fois alerté le gouvernement sur
l'inquiétude des français pour notre
système de santé les tensions les
souffrances sont grande parmi les
soignants aggravée par un sentiment
d'injustice profonde de celles et ceux
qui sont aussi au front aides soignants
infirmières à domicile qui sont employés
des collectivités des associations
et qui ne sont pas reconnus de la même
façon par le ségur souffrance également
chez les personnels hospitaliers qui
sont sous pression permanente en
particulier aux urgences avec des
services qui ferme la nuit dans de plus
en plus d'hôpitaux faute de praticiens
et nous le savons la situation critique
dans nos hôpitaux est aussi une
conséquence directe de la
désertification médicale avec des
patients qui se tourne vers l'hôpital
parce qu'ils n'ont plus d'autre solution
et je peux vous dire que le nouveau
forfait à 19 euros aux urgences est
vécue comme une double peine pour ceux
qui n'ont ni mutuelle ni médecin
traitant alors tout doit être fait pour
stopper cette désertification qui ne
fait que s'aggraver année après année et
qui est une hygiène inégalités majeure
entre les citoyens alors je défendrai
ici au nom de notre groupe le 20 janvier
une loi pour proposer des solutions
d'urgence et traiter le problème
maintenant pas demain maintenant parce
que c'est maintenant que le problème se
pose monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement est il prêt à soutenir des
mesures fortes de régulation de la
présence médicale pour garantir à tous
l'accès un médecin généraliste et
spécialiste en proximité je vous
remercie merci monsieur gao la parole
est à monsieur olivier ferrand ministre
des solidarités il a chanté monsieur le
député guillaume garot le gouvernement
sera toujours favorable pour accueillir
deux dispositions pour lutter contre les
déserts médicaux dès lors qu'elles sont
bonnes et applicables en revanche il
s'opposera à systématiquement mesure
lorsqu'elle ne seront pas applicables ou
non adaptés si vous faites allusion à la
coercition à la régulation à
l'installation j'ai eu l'occasion de
répondre je crois à quinze propositions
de loi depuis le début de ce mandat est
d'abord comme parlementaire rapporteur
et ensuite comme ministre avec c'est
toujours cette question qui revient de
savoir pourquoi est ce qu ont contraint
pas les gens à s'installer on ne
contraint pas les gens à s'installer
parce qu'on en a pas pas d pad et pas de
contraintes des gens vous n'avez pas
assez de médecins c'est une manifeste et
c'est nationale il n'y a pas une zone
surdotée des zones sous dotées il est
des zones sous-dotées et des zones très
sous-dotées la réaction la plus
pragmatique c'est 2018 c'est la
suppression du numerus clausus et vous
en êtes d'accord monsieur garot nous
avons passé la formation des premières
années de médecine de 8000 à 10000 500
euros c'est 15% de plus déjà et ça va
continuer d'augmenter
ça va continuer d'augmenter le président
de la république avait fixé un objectif
doubler le nombre de maisons de santé
pluriprofessionnelle dans le mandat nous
le ferons nous l'aurons fait doubler le
nombre de deux centres de santé nous
sommes en train d'y arriver nous avons
fait du x 100 pour la télémédecine dans
notre pays nous avons créé et développé
les fameuses cpts avec ma santé 2022 des
centaines voit le jour sur tout le
territoire vous avez eu l'occasion de
voter des délégations de tâches des
transferts de compétences de l'équipe
l'exercice pluri professionnelle pour
permettre d'épargner du temps médical
plus de 2000 assistants médicaux sont
déployés sur tout le territoire national
pour permettre à des médecins de faire
autre chose que la paperasserie bref
nous continuons d'agir et toutes les
mesures et toutes les idées que vous lui
soumettrai si elles vont dans le bon
sens on les regardera ensemble parce que
la responsabilité elle est collective du
numerus clausus et ces désastres
aujourd'hui les solutions peut les
trouver ensemble mais encore une fois ne
faites pas croire aux français qu'il
suffirait d'imposer pour que ça
fonctionne ce n'est pas vrai
non merci mr la parole est un monsieur
philippe chalumeau merci merci monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues question
monsieur mise de solidarité de la santé
sur les révérends alors qu'une cinquième
vague épidémique submerge une nouvelle
fois notre pays il est du devoir de
chaque parlementaire de prendre ses
responsabilités sans délai afin de jouer
pleinement son rôle en soutien et en
complément de tous nos concitoyens pour
participer à sa juste place au
dispositif collectif de protection de
tous et de chacun je conçois en effet
notre action comme un renfort apporté à
nos soignants et à tous ceux qui dans le
cadre de leur activité professionnelle
ou de leur engagement associatif
agissent en synergie pour contrer les
effets de la crise sanitaire sur nos
vies et notre pays parmi les très
nombreux outils de gestion d'incitation
et d'accompagnement de cette crise
sanitaire que nous avons déjà mis en
place au travers des dix textes de lois
adoptées depuis deux ans maintenant
le déploiement massif de la vaccination
est sans aucun doute le plus efficace
car il est acquis désormais qu'il réduit
par dix le potentiel individuel
contaminants et qu'il protège des formes
graves de la maladie une étude publiée
le 13 décembre dernier par la célèbre
revue the lancet est unanimement
reconnue a démontré qu'une augmentation
de la couverture vaccinale a été
observée dans les pays qui ont introduit
des passes sanitaire en france il reste
cependant 5 millions de nos concitoyens
qui ne sont pas encore vaccinés face à
la très grande contagiosité du variant
au micro il constitue de fait un
important réservoir de diffusion du
virus et ils sont plus fragiles nous
devons donc nous donner les moyens
d'améliorer autant que possible la
couverture vaccinale dans notre pays les
mesures courageuses qui restent à
prendre seront donc nécessairement
temporaire et limitée à la période la
plus critique de celui sont actuellement
aussi monsieur le ministre pouvez vous
nous donner les informations les plus
précises et récente à votre disposition
mr sur la ligne éthique prévisionnelle
d'évolution de l'épidémie nous l'offrir
ainsi la parole est à monsieur le
ministre de la santé et des solidarités
monsieur olivier veyrat
monsieur le député philippe chalumeau
merci pour votre question j'ai dit tout
à l'heure nous serons probablement aux
alentours des 300 milles contamination
sur 24 heures ça donne un vertige quand
on se rappelle des chiffres de
contamination que nous avons connu
depuis le début de la pandémie nous ne
sommes pas surpris nous savons le
variant omicron très contagieux les
données qui nous reviennent d'angleterre
de danemark et des pays qui ont été
touchés avant nous attestent de manière
certaine que le vaccin est notamment
avec la vaccination de rappel protéger
formidable c'est important encore une
fois les vaccins habituels modern art is
either n'empêche pas les contaminations
avec le barrio mikron par contre elles
empêchent le développement du virus
quand il vous a contaminé sa
multiplication dans les poumons et donc
évite l'apparition de formes graves un
chiffre que je peux vous donner qui est
une donnée que nous avons faits dont
nous avons fait le calcul sur la base
des informations que nous avions c'est
que pour un malade vacciner avec rappel
en réanimation il y a vingt malades non
vaccinées dans notre animation 20 pour 1
pour celles et ceux qui doutent de
l'intérêt de se faire vacciner
vous l'avez rappelé le passe à lithaire
heureusement et merci d'avoir voté
courageusement déjà à l'époque parce que
cette 12.5 millions de français qui
n'étaient pas vaccinés qui se sont fait
vacciner depuis la simple annonce par le
premier ministre de l'arrivée prochaine
du pass vaccinale nous avons doublé le
rythme de vaccinations quotidiennes des
français en primo vaccination qui
n'avait pas encore été vaccinés ça veut
dire que chaque jour mesdames et
messieurs les députés avec ces
dispositifs certes vécu comme
contraignant nous l'entendons mais c'est
une contrainte pour sauver des vies
encore une fois et bien il y a des
dizaines de milliers de français qui se
protège et donc ça fait des centaines de
patients qui ne vont pas à l'hôpital ou
qui n'auront pas sur le médecin et des
dizaines qui ne vont pas en réanimation
c'est le chemin que nous avons tracé le
chemin que nous continuerons de suivre
jusqu'à ce que nous puissions enfin
sortir de cette pandémie et là
évidemment c'est avec un plaisir partagé
que nous lèverons toute forme de
contraintes qui pèsent sur notre société
depuis un moment
la parole est un monsieur loïc
prud'hommes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale c'est
par la presse que les personnels ont
pris connaissance dimanche soir de la
façon dont la rentrée devait être
organisé dans les écoles collèges lycées
autre protocole fantoche qui continuent
à s'alléger proportionnellement à la
progression de la cinquième vague les
mesures incohérentes ou floue qui
permettent par exemple des cantines
bondé mais interdisent le café debout en
salle des profs etc etc tout cela dans
le plus profond irrespect des
enseignants des directeurs et
directrices dont vous méprisez
l'engagement et la compétence pour
préparer des modalités d'enseignement
intelligente et adaptez vous expliquer
hier votre improvisation prétextant
coller à la réalité de la pandémie ah
bon vous êtes donc le seul qui n'était
pas au courant dès novembre de la
présence du variant au micron en france
la vague était prévisible avant même les
vacances de noël et vous n'avez rien
anticipé comme toujours pas de masques
ffp2 fournit aux enseignants pas de
détecteur de co2 ni de purificateurs
d'air comme nous vous le proposons
depuis bientôt deux ans pire votre
majorité a voté hier soir contre le
principe même de leur déploiement ne pas
sécuriser l'école est irresponsable et
injustifiable quand on prétend protéger
la santé des français
factuellement vous n'avez que faire de
la santé des gens pour preuve vous
rappelez des enseignants retraités plus
vulnérables qu'ovide pour pallier à
l'absence de remplaçants dans les
classes et vous vous en vanter oui car
ce chaos vous l'organiser de longue date
5900 pas supprimés dans l'éducation
nationale depuis du 1017 moyens
matériels dérisoire à louer
aujourd'hui vous préparez l'effondrement
du système par votre inconséquence
monsieur le ministre quand allez vous
enfin prendre la seule mesure sanitaire
urgentes qui s'imposent pour sauver
notre système scolaire préserver ses
personnels et les élèves votre mise à
l'isolément complet et définitif merci
monsieur le député la parole et à
monsieur jean michel blanquer
musée l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse et des sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
loïc prud'hommes depuis deux ans je fais
un voeu mais qui est un voeu pieux qui
serait de réussir à avoir un consensus
sur ces bancs sur le sujet scolaires qui
le méritent et toutes les données sont
sur la table et en réalité vous savez
très bien que la chaque fois nous sommes
dans un rapport avantages inconvénients
dans toutes les décisions que nous
prenons
si j'avais suivi vos avis et vos
recommandations depuis le début de cette
crise la france serait sans doute partie
des pays qui aurait le plus fermé leur
école parce que la pomme de la démagogie
est toujours celle que vous choisissez
et chacun peut se référer à vos
interventions depuis deux ans une fois
de plus ce que nous avons voulu c'est
privilégier nos enfants c'est pourquoi
très vite nous avons dit que
l'information principale c'est à dire
que l'école serait ouverte à la rentrée
c'est ce qui s'est passé et c'est la
décision de principe que le conseil de
défense a prise lundi dernier et dès
mardi j'en ai parlé et j'ai dit que ce
qui changerait le plus ce serait la
politique de tests c'est ce qui s'est
passé comme je l'expliquais tout à
l'heure mais vous préférez répéter un
mensonge que d'écouter une vérité et
bien c'est à partir du 31 que nous avons
pu travailler à partir de ce que nous a
demandé le haut conseil à la santé
publique et de la dire comme je l'avais
annoncé seulement le dimanche en effet
parce que c'est ainsi les règles qui
s'appliquaient au demeurant ce qui s'est
passé lundi matin n'était en rien
différent de ce qui se passait avant les
vacances c'est la politique de test dans
les jours suivants qui change donc il
n'y a pas eu d' adaptation particulière
à avoir le matin tous ces éléments sont
clairs objectifs bien sûr ils comportent
leurs inconvénients bien sûr c'est
difficile sur le terrain je suis le
premier à le savoir
simplement on voit ce qui dans ce genre
de circonstance cherche à mettre de
l'huile sur le feu vous encore et
toujours et ceux qui travaillent sur le
terrain derrière les professeurs pour
tout simplement accueillir nos enfants
et le faire dans les conditions de
sécurité maximales c'est ce que nos
protocoles ont permis au premier
trimestre je vous remercie merci la
parole est à monsieur bruno bilde
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre
cinq ans pour rien c'est le titre de
votre bilan sur l'emploi cinq ans pour
rien plus de 6 millions de chômeurs
attendent toujours que jupiter leur
fasse traverser la rue pour trouver un
travail contrairement aux mensonges de
voeux présidentiels le chômage n'a pas
reculé d'un pouce des plans sociaux eux
se sont multipliés chez moi dans le
pas-de-calais je pense particulièrement
aux 75 sacrifiés du site de maxam à
mazingarbe et aux 118 salariés victimes
de la fermeture brutale de france
loisirs parce que c'est votre bilan sur
le pouvoir d'achat cinq ans pour rien
vous avez fait les poches des retraités
avec la hausse de la csg est celle des
jeunes avec la baisse des apl en
refusant de baisser les taxes sur les
énergies et les carburants vous avez
aggraver la situation des plus modestes
deux français sur dix ont froid chez eux
un français sur quatre ne mange pas à sa
faim un français sur trois ne se soigne
pas pour des raisons économiques parce
que c'est votre bilan sur la sécurité
cinq ans pour rien une agression
gratuite août les 44 secondes 85 actes
de violences par jour contre nos forces
de l'ordre des émeutes urbaines quasi
quotidiennes des zones de non france
jamais les français n'ont été autant en
insécurité physique parce que c'est
votre bilan sur la démocratie cinq ans
pour rien en 2007 le candidat macron
s'était engagé à créer une banque de la
démocratie et instaurer la
proportionnelle malgré le mouvement des
gilets jaunes et une abstention
terrifiante aux élections locales vous
avez enterré vos belles promesses parce
que c'est votre bilan en cinq ans vous
avez porté atteinte à nos libertés
individuelles en imposant des
restrictions absurde en divisant les
français allant même jusqu'à imposer le
masque à l'extérieur aux enfants de 6
ans tout en décernant la légion
d'honneur agnès buzyn alors monsieur le
premier ministre allez vous enfin
déposez votre bilan
la parole est à monsieur olivier du top
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député bill vous avez essayé vous avez
essayé de tracer un bilan ce la réalité
c'est vous ne connaissez pas ce pays
vous ne connaissez pas se payer je crois
que vous ne connaissez pas votre
département dans votre département du
pas de calais le nombre de bénéficiaires
du rsa a baissé de 10% grâce à qui à
cette majorité pas grâce à vous au
niveau du pays nous avons le taux de
chômage est moins élevé depuis 15 ans
grâce à kippa grâce à vous au niveau de
la sécurité vous en avez parlé qui a ré
valoriser les moyens du ministère de
l'intérieur comme jamais c'est ce
gouvernement sous l'autorité du premier
ministre avec gérald darmanin qui a
valorisé les moyens des armées c'est ce
gouvernement qui a revalorisé les moyens
des hôpitaux c'est encore ce
gouvernement monsieur le député vous
essayé vainement de vous prêter à une
forme de provocation qui ne peut que
vous allez mais qui n'est pas efficace
vous n'avez pas de programme vous n'avez
pas de bilan vous n'avez pas d'actions
votre bilan à vous c'est le silence et
la protestation
c'est l'inefficacité et le populisme
votre programme c'est le néant votre
horizon sais rien vous êtes condamnés à
ne rien faire à ne rien penser et à ne
jamais avoir de bilan à présenter devant
les français parce que le contraire de
ce que vous défendez le contraire de ce
que vous proposez c'est la vacuité votre
projet
merci
la parole est à madame blandine gros cas
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
alors que certaines catégories
d'entreprises commencé à reprendre leur
souffle
la nouvelle flambée de qu'ovide les met
à nouveau en difficulté
je pense notamment au secteur de la
restauration de la nuit de la culture du
tourisme et au secteur de l'événementiel
pour lesquels les limitations d'accueil
où les jauges font craindre une perte
substantielle de chiffre d'affaires
l'annulation de la plupart des
manifestations et rassemblements ans en
particulier à nos cérémonies des voeux
par exemple ou l'interdiction de
consommation debout on tue un impact
immédiat sur les secteurs de la
restauration sur les traiteurs les
entreprises événementielle qui ont vu
l'annulation de contrats en dernière
minute sans forcément pouvoir recourir à
l'activité partielle
depuis presque deux ans maintenant des
dispositifs exceptionnels ont été mises
en place pour soutenir toutes nos
entreprises touchées par la crise des
dispositifs sincèrement saluée par tous
les ans preneur entrepreneurs avec
lesquels j'ai changé ces derniers mois
ils ont été essentielles pour leur
permettre de rebondir d'éviter des
licenciements la grande simplicité de
mise en oeuvre est également saluée par
tous elle leur a permis de se concentrer
sur l'essentiel maintenir l'activité à
son maximum et préparer le rebond
à l'heure où l'on ose encore entrevoir
une possible sortie de crise il est
toujours aussi important de ne laisser
personne sur le bord du chemin et de
continuer à aider les secteurs à nouveau
mise en difficulté ainsi que ceux qui
permettront encore de longs mois avant
de se relever monsieur le ministre la
question est simple mais elles
concernent le quotidien et l'avenir de
millions de français quelles aides et
mesures prévoyez vous pour soutenir
encore ces entreprises merci mme la
députée la parole est un monsieur le
ministre délégué chargé du tourisme et
les petites et moyennes entreprises
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée blandine brocard l'état a été
là vous l'avez souligné l'état continue
d'être là au côté de ces entreprises de
ces secteurs repris plus
particulièrement impactés
hier avec elisabeth bornes avec bruno le
maire nous avons réuni justement une
bonne partie de ces secteurs impactés
l'hôtellerie la restauration le monde de
la nuit et d'autres encore et nous
allons poursuivre avec le monde du sport
le monde de la culture demain avec
roselyne bachelot et nous avons sous
l'autorité du premier ministre activer
des outils bien connu des entrepreneurs
et efficace le dispositif coûts fixes
accessible dès 50 % de perte de chiffre
d'affaires est étendu à l'ensemble de ce
qu'on appelle le secteur est ce un bisou
le savez ça couvre le monde du tourisme
au sens large est très large et surtout
on met en place une procédure de
traitement très rapide des dossiers pour
tous les dossiers de moins 50000 euros
ces deux tiers des dossiers par ailleurs
l'activité partielle et isabelle borne
l'a dit est désormais accessible non
seulement pour les entreprises qui
perdent 65 % de leur chiffre d'affaires
mais également auprès des entreprises
qui subissent des contraintes sanitaires
donc c'est très important ça permette
d'élargir le champ également des
bénéficiaires et puis bruno le maire l'a
confirmé ce matin sur les prêts garantis
par l'état pour les entreprises qui
connaîtraient des difficultés grâce à la
médiation du crédit il va être possible
de d'étaler dans le temps jusqu'à 10 ans
ou de reporter de quelques mois le début
des remboursements réponse très attendue
cet effort national pour l'économie bleu
blanc rouge nous l'assumons à 100 %
depuis le début de la crise 240
milliards d'euros il ne s'agit pas de
cramer la caisse il s'agit d'éviter de
cramer des emplois et d'éviter de cramer
des entreprises ça fait une grande
différence avec ceux qui ont géré la
crise ya dix ans qui maniait la matraque
fiscal 15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires en 2012 lorsque nous
baissons le budget et qu'olivier du stop
de 10 milliards d'euros au plan de
rigueur nous préférons les plans de
vigueur et ça nous allons continuer avec
vous avec cette majorité pour le tissu
entrepreneurial français
merci la parole est à madame valérie
chic si monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
alors que la vaccination est désormais
ouverte aux enfants de 5 à 11 ans et que
les plus de 18 ans sont éligibles à la
troisième dose les adolescents de 12 à
18 ans eux restent dans le flou
intégré dans le projet de loi
transformant le pass sanitaire en passe
vaccinale les adolescents ne semble pas
concerné par la troisième dose les
parents s'interrogent et s'inquiètent
leurs craintes se pose avec d'autant
plus d'acuité que les adolescents ont de
multiples europe sociaux et d'ailleurs
le taux d'incidents chez les lycéens en
atteste car avec 1714 cas pour 100000
habitants les lycéens se contaminent
plus que toute autre catégorie de
population
les adolescents s'interroge aussi sur la
validité de leurs passes sera-t-il
toujours valable leur demandera ton
d'effectuer un rappel dans la
précipitation conditionnant la
préservation de leur liberté qu'en
est-il de l'immunité de ces adolescents
pour qui l'ouverture à la deuxième
d'autres doses daz déjà depuis plus de
six mois alors qu'il paraît admis que la
protection immunitaire conférée par la
vaccination des croix après six mois si
d'aventuré les adolescents étaient
éligibles à la troisième dose de quel
vaccin s'agirait-il sur est il question
d'une dose similaire à celle administrée
aux enfants ou une dose adulte en bref
monsieur premier ministre quelle est la
trajectoire du gouvernement sur la
vaccination des jeunes de 12 à 18 ans
merci madame la députée la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé
valérie six merci pour votre question
sur la vaccination des adolescents
d'abord vous dire que dans notre pays 80
% des adolescents ont reçu au moins une
dose c'est près de 78% qui ont un schéma
vaccinal complet à l'heure à laquelle je
vous parle les autorités sanitaires
scientifiques notamment la haute
autorité de santé ne recommande pas de
troisième dose de dose de rappel pour
les adolescents si les imbéciles de les
données scientifiques devaient être
évoluer alors nous ouvririons évidemment
la troisième dose à 12h appel aux
adolescents à l'heure actuelle je le
redis ce n'est pas le cas quelques pays
ont proposé leur appel aux 16 17 ans
notamment n'est pas le cas en france et
je n'ai pas d'indication comme tel nous
serions en mesure de le faire si on nous
donnait le feu vert je préfère le
répéter pour que ce soit bien clair ça
veut dire qu'il reste encore des ados
qui ne sont pas vaccinés les ados qui ne
sont pas vaccinés aujourd'hui ce sont
pour l'essentiel d'ailleurs pour une
partie d'entre eux non négligeable les
enfants des adultes qui ne sont pas
vaccinés d'ailleurs dans le débat qu'on
nous aurons cet après midi sur le pass
vaccinale chez les 12 17 ans c'est un
argument que je mettrai en avant hier
que les enfants les adolescents
qui seraient privés de restaurants ou de
cinéma parce qu'ils ne seraient pas
vaccinés en réalité les parents en
général ne sont pas vaccinés eux mêmes
ne vont donc pas au cinéma ne vont pas
au restaurant donc la question ne se
pose pas vraiment à la marge en revanche
on a bien vu que le passe l'intégration
des ados dans le pass il avait soulevé
beaucoup de questions à l'époque
souvenez-vous au parlement ça s'est très
bien passé et c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs
nous affichons un taux de couverture
vaccinale qui est important elle est
très bien toléré elle est très efficace
c'était des dozos finder qui était
proposé aux 12-17 ans il y avait un
rappel ce serait même vaccin mais encore
une fois aujourd'hui elle n'est pas
ouverte juste parce j'ai répondu à
toutes vos questions madame la députée
il y en avait il y en avait beaucoup
mais je reste à votre disposition si
nécessaire
merci madame fixerait peut-être juste eu
à compléter ce et ceux qui ont été
vaccinés qui ont déjà eu leur deuxième
dose arrive enfin d'une unité puisqu'ils
ont déjà placé six mois qu'en est il
pour eux monsieur le ministre
je vous ai répondu qu à ce stade les
autorités sanitaires que j'ai saisi de
la question considère qu'il n'y a pas
lieu de proposer un rappel à ce public
même arrivé à six mois ce qui veut dire
qu'il garde le bénéfice de leurs pattes
rien ne change
merci la parole est à m virginie duby
muller
monsieur le président madame la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur à la
mi-décembre klaus kinsler professeur
d'allemand depuis 26 ans à l'institut
d'études politiques de grenoble où j'ai
eu la chance d'étudier a été suspendu
par sa direction pendant quatre mois
cette affaire est d'une gravité sans nom
en mars dernier lors de l'organisation
d'une journée de débat sur le racisme
l'islamophobie et l'antisémitisme
claus kinsler a estimé que ces trois
notions ne devait pas être mis sur un
pied d'égalité
deux syndicats étudiants issus de la
mouvance islamo gauchistes ont alors
lancé une véritable fatwa contre lui et
sa collègue co organisatrice des débats
en appelant à un lynchage collectif
cette cabale a conduit à la mise sous
protection policière de ces deux
professeurs afin qu'il ne subisse pas le
même sort que samuel pâtit devant la
gravité de ces faits une sanction
exemplaire était attendu or la
commission disciplines de sciences po
grenoble s'est contenté de relaxer les
dix sept étudiants mis-en-cause preuve
de la dérive idéologique manifeste de la
direction cet établissement
non seulement l'ump a donné un
blanc-seing ceux qui voudraient mettre
une cible dans le dos du professeur mais
il punit désormais la victime la mise à
pied de claus kinsler est inacceptable
quelle est sa faute d'avoir soi disant
tenu des propos diffamatoires à
l'encontre de sciences po grenoble qui
ne l'a pas soutenu de nombreuses voix
s'élèvent aujourd'hui pour dénoncer ce
traitement inique
à commencer par jean michel blanquer air
qui a qualifié cette suspension d'
erreurs formelles une quarantaine
d'intellectuels chercheurs et historiens
ont pris la défense de klaus kinsler et
une pétition de soutien a reçu plus de
onze mille cinq cents signatures
madame la ministre en mars je vous avais
déjà interrogé sur l'initiative de
damien abad et julien aubert demandant
la création d'une mission d'information
sur la culture de l'annulation et
l'islamo gauchisme dans le milieu
universitaire quand allez vous enfin
agir que comptez vous faire pour
garantir la liberté d'expression et
d'enseignement dans une eau universités
et ep quand allez-vous mettre un terme à
l'infiltration de set quand cette
culture qui propage la haine et fait
régner la terreur et de la députée la
parole éternelle frédéric vidal ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur de la
recherche et de l'innovation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
vous avez rappelé les faits
effectivement en mars 2021 des
inscriptions à l'encontre de deux
professeurs qui ont été condamnés par
l'immense majorité des enseignants de
sciences po grenoble et des étudiants de
sciences po grenoble commis par un petit
groupe d'étudiants qui sont passés en
conseil de discipline non pas à grenoble
parce que évidemment la sphère a été
dépaysé et pour lesquels des sanctions
ont été retenus pour une
de ses étudiantes uniquement des les
faits j'ai diligenté une mission de
l'inspection générale qui a permis d'une
part de mettre en place ce processus
disciplinaire envers les étudiants qui a
permis aussi de rappeler à l'ensemble
des protagonistes de cette affaire qui
avaient tous si vous aviez lu les
conclusions publiques du rapport vous en
seriez rendu compte qu'ils avaient tous
exagéré dans ce contexte et en rappel a
donc été fait et puis un accompagnement
de la direction de grenoble par
l'inspection générale cet accompagnement
il se poursuit et je crois que c'est
important que nous puissions ramener de
la sérénité dans cet établissement gars
qu'est ce que vous faites vous
stigmatisez 600 enseignants rue
stigmatiser 3000 étudiants cet ep
simplement parce que monsieur kinsler
fait joue
effectivement il a un devoir de réserve
en tant que fonctionnaire vis-à-vis de
son institution et c'est ça qu'il faut
aussi être capable de rappeler je crois
que ça n'a aucun sens de stigmatiser une
école entière ce gouvernement est pour
le respect des enseignants pour
l'accompagnement des étudiants
certainement pas pour des polémiques
futiles sur des raisons qui n'ont pas
lieu d'être merci mal à m'y attendais ne
1 1 mes chers collègues on va poursuivre
nos travaux la parole est à monsieur
denis sommaire merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de l'industrie madame la
ministre l'industrie automobile traverse
des mutations d'une ampleur considérable
et sommes dans un temps extrêmement
court puisqu'il s'agit de mettre en
place des nouveaux systèmes de mobilité
complètement renouvelée d'ici 2030 huit
années pour transformer cette industrie
et l'ensemble de la chaîne de valeur est
concerné il nous faut à la fois met sur
le marché de nouveaux produits produire
des batteries et développer la
production de microprocesseurs
organiser la filière hydrogène afin
d'assurer notre indépendance nationale
et européenne
multipliez l'installation de bornes de
rechange de recharge pardon mais aussi
réorganiser et c'est pas le moindre des
sujets
réorganiser la sous-traitance et
l'ouvrir à de nouveaux marchés tout en
l'encourageant à moderniser ses moyens
de production et former le personnel
huit années de recherche de
modernisation numérisation huit années à
l'échelle industrielle c'est demain
aussi nous devons être très attentifs et
mobilisés pour la filière est tout
particulièrement pour les entreprises
petites et moyennes qui la composent
très mobilisés pour accompagner les
salariés les territoires elle nord
franche comté ont fait partie j'ai
réalisé un rapport il y à peu sur les
relations donneurs d'ordre sous traitant
et il apparaît clairement que
après de multiples auditions que la
solidarité de filière n'est pas
forcément la valeur la plus partagée
dans cette filière automobile alors
qu'il existe énormément de savoir faire
dans ces petites et moyennes entreprises
après l'annnonce du ministre des
transports de consacrer 500 millions
d'euros supplémentaires à au déploiement
des bornes de recharge pour les
véhicules électriques vous avez madame
la ministre décidé de lancer un plan
d'accompagnement des sous traitants à
hauteur de 400 millions d'euros madame
2010 pouvez vous nous préciser le
contenu et le calendrier de mise en
oeuvre de ce plan merci monsieur député
la parole est à madame agnès pannier une
hache et ministre délégué chargé de
l'industrie
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député sommaire chacun
connaît votre expertise de ce secteur de
parrot carrière professionnelle mais
également votre engagement sur un
territoire qui en est un des fleurons et
vous avez raison le secteur automobile
trans traverse une transformation
absolument fondamental vous avez parlé
de la voiture décarbonée on pourrait
aussi parler la voiture autonome de la
voiture connectée et cette
transformation elle va se faire dans un
temps extrêmement court et donc nous en
tant que responsables politiques nous
devons accompagner les sous-traitants de
la filière et les salariés de cette
filière et c'est ce que nous faisons
depuis 2010 est parce que depuis 2010
est je veux le rappeler avec la mise en
place d'une filière de batteries
électriques qui n'existait pas en france
avec la mise en place d'une filière
hydrogène qui n'existait pas en france
avec tout le travail que nous avons mené
d'accompagnement des compétences et je
regarde ma collègue elisabeth bornes
clés comme totalement investis sur ce
travail de formation professionnelle et
de transformation des compétences avec
le plan des ailes et plus récemment le
plan de relance nous avons pris à bras
le corps cette situation alors
aujourd'hui déjà 400 entreprises de la
filière de la sous traitance des pme
essentiellement ont vu leurs projets de
transformation accélérée grâce au plan
de relance
aujourd'hui nous allons avec le plan
france 2030 continuer cet accompagnement
le rendre plus structurant puisque nous
avons lancé dès fin décembre un appel à
projets donc ces 400 millions d'euros
que j'ai annoncé céder 400 millions qui
sont aujourd'hui en cours de déploiement
nous n'attendons pas l'appel à projets a
été lancé fin décembre il permettra
d'ici la fin du premier trimestre
d'accompagner de nouvelles pme dans leur
transformation et nous avons avec
elisabeth bornes de nouveaux projets
d'accompagnement pour les salariés
travers notamment de l' académie de la
batterie électrique et d'autres
dispositifs je vous remercie madame la
ministre
la parole est à monsieur paul andret
colombani merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
chers collègues le renforcement de la
lutte contre la circulation des faux pas
sanitaire est une des priorités de votre
projet de loi relatif à la gestion de la
crise sanitaire que nous examinons en ce
moment même
180 2000 c'est le nombre de faux passe
en circulation dont nous avait fait état
un chiffre probablement encore très
sous-évalué puisqu'il prend uniquement
en compte les fraudes avérées les
réseaux d'élaboration et de vente de
faux parce fleurissent notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux alors que vous aviez
tenté vous aviez vanter les mérites de
ce système soit disant violable nous
apprenons par la presse que les
faussaires profite pourtant
d'importantes failles de sécurité ces
failles permettent d'accéder très
facilement sur dr libre des données
confidentielles et de s'introduire sur
le site de l'assurance maladie pour
générer automatiquement des vrais faux
parce
ce qui est particulièrement
problématique au delà de l'existence de
telles failles c'est que ces vrais faux
pas s'identifier par vos services ne
sont pas désactiver les chiffres là
aussi sont accablants à la date du 29
décembre on comptait 3600 passe sur
liste noire sur les 182 me de repérer
faute d'outils techniques permettant de
désactiver les faux-pas ce dans le cadre
de procédures judiciaires leur
circulation jette également l'opprobre
sur les professionnels de santé qui ont
vu leurs identifiants piratés
cet immense trou dans la raquette est
très inquiétant au moment où vous
souhaitez faire évoluer un dispositif
qui n'est toujours pas correctement mis
en oeuvre sur le plan technique monsieur
le ministre que comptez vous faire pour
combler les failles de sécurité
existantes et désactiver au plus vite
les passes frauduleux aujourd'hui en
circulation je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député comme vous nous sommes
particulièrement scandalisé par
l'utilisation des faux-pas sanitaires et
nous les condamnons bien sûr dans leur
utilisation mais nous poursuivons à
quels services de monsieur le ministre
la justice ces personnes dépositaire ou
utilisateurs de ces faux pas ce
salutaire depuis
le début de le pass sanitaires et
jusqu'au 30 décembre dernier
1919 verbalisations ont été adressées
pour quelqu'un qui a un passé ni terme
et la prêter à quelqu'un d'autre c'est à
dire à passe appartenant à un tiers
c'est à dire 11 % d'augmentation ne
serait-ce que la dernière semaine du
mois de décembre mais plus grave encore
si j'ose dire nous comptons ministère de
l'intérieur entre la police la
gendarmerie le constat de 192 1483
faux-pas sanitaire au 30 décembre
dernier avec 435 au moment où je parle
ouverture d' enquête judiciaire par les
services de monsieur mise la justice un
peu plus zone police qu'en zone
gendarmerie mais très équilibré
malheureusement sur le territoire j'ai
demandé particulièrement au service
d'investigation cyber d'être
particulièrement attentifs le comme
cyber jantes pour la gendarmerie la dcpj
pour la police nationale puisque nous
avons constaté que de très nombreuses
désormais mode d'action cybercriminels
était responsable de la production de
ses passes et je constate avec vous que
deux grandes enquêtes sider d'envergure
ont eu lieu à lyon et à paris et qui ont
montré que des piratage des sites des
médecins ou des cabinets médicaux et pas
simplement de l'assurance maladie ont
été responsables de ces faux parce
sanitaires une vingtaine de dossiers ont
été traités par pour 150 trafiquants et
bénéficiaires entendu ne serait-ce que
ces dernières heures encore encore une
fois récemment à bordeaux dans le cas
d'une affaire qui touchait
particulièrement la jirs de nancy deux
personnes ont été interpellées à la
demande du ministère de la justice avec
un bénéfice monsieur le député et
d'avoirs criminels de 2,8 millions
d'euros pour engendrer c'est faux parce
comprenez bien que la taxe ibères elle
est partout sur le territoire national
et elle touche qu'il faut pas s'arrêter
à cette élection monsieur qu'on l'a
gagné
merci la parole est à monsieur sébastien
huyghe
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
si des ministres ont des récriminations
affaires sur la période 2007 à 2012 je
leur suggère de régler leurs comptes
avec monsieur castex qui avait un poste
éminent à l'elysée pendant cette époque
s'adresse à monsieur verront comme un
monsieur dupont moretti ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre je veux vous
alerter sur une note de la cour des
comptes qui révèle que les effectifs de
policiers de gendarmes mobilisés pour
assurer l'ordre public ont diminué entre
2011 et 2020 pire ce rapport confirme
que le taux d'engagement des policiers
sur le terrain a également baissé sur la
même période contrairement à tout ce que
votre majorité a voulu faire croire
depuis cinq ans il y avait donc
davantage de forces de l'ordre sur le
terrain sous nicolas sarkozy que sous un
manuel macron et ce manque de fuzz de
forces de l'ordre sur le terrain n'est
hélas pas sans conséquence puisque le
taux d'élucidation des homicides et des
cambriolages est en baisse enfin ce
rapport confirme que la réforme que vous
avez mis en place pour créer la police
de sécurité du quotidien est un échec
mes chers collègues nos deux cent
cinquante mille policiers et gendarmes
sont essentiels à la sécurité à la
tranquillité des français ils font un
travail admirable dans des conditions
très difficiles et souvent dangereuse et
je tiens à les saluer tout
particulièrement ce début d'année de
2022 mais nos forces de l'ordre ne
peuvent pas être livrées à elles-mêmes
ou être écrasé par le poids des tâches
administratives
il faut en finir avec cette organisation
trop bureaucratique qui les empêchent
d'être sur le terrain au service de nos
concitoyens et notamment des femmes
victimes de violence comme nous en
déplorons la cruelle actualité
monsieur le ministre alors que le
président macron a trop souvent négligé
la mission de sécurité de l'état êtes
vous prêt à suivre les enseignements de
ce rapport pour enrayer enfin cette
hausse
inacceptable de la délinquance dans
notre pays
si monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
madame la députée monsieur le député
sébastien huyghe
je trouve qu'il vous faut une certaine
dose d'originalité
voir d'humour pour expliquer que c'est
ce gouvernement si camille monde
policier je veux au contraire vous dire
la grande différence entre deux
ministres et comptes publics seuls que
fut madame pécresse qui a supprimé 12
1500 postes lorsqu'elle était en
responsabilité
et la chose que j'ai pu servir le
gouvernement est désormais lié du soft
c'est de créer dix mille postes de
policiers et gendarmes supplémentaires
c'est tellement vrai monsieur vig que
vous avez été un de ceux qui m'a
notamment remercié parce qu'on a mis
enfin 150 policiers supplémentaires dans
la métropole de lille vous m'avez même
récemment je cois écrit pour le
commissariat de wattignies et je me suis
perdu d'art de vous répondre
positivement et je trouve ça très normal
même si vous votez pas depuis quatre ans
les budgets qui donne plus de moyens aux
forces de l'ordre
et vous savez monsieur league ce qui
m'inquiète beaucoup c'est que vous allez
chercher dans les rapports de la cour
des comptes encore une fois vision
comptable ce qu'ils ont à faire pour la
police nationale moi je vous encourage
tout en écoutant ce que dit la cour
d'abord de voir les transformations
qu'on a fait on a mis fin à la vacation
forte 1250 policiers qui sont denses et
déjà depuis le début de l'année en plus
par terre devant les difficultés de la
queue de la délinquance pourquoi parce
qu'on a mis fin à des cycles peut-être
un peu trop généreux mais aussi des
mutations de policiers qui permettre il
faut bien les écouter ainsi de pouvoir
mettre les policiers on a besoin d'eux
et quitter les grandes métropoles et
ile-de-france malheureusement parce
qu'elle n'est pas assez de contraintes
pour les permettre de rester là où ils
devaient rester mais enfin monsieur vick
ne dit pas où est ce que vous avez
supprimé les deux cent mille postes de
fonctionnaires annoncé pendant pécresse
allez-vous encore supprimer des
policiers des gendarmes
allez vous encore le faire
répondez à cette question simple allez
vous supprimez des postes de
fonctionnaires de police et gendarmerie
malheureusement le passé c'est oui
heureusement que nous étions là pour
réparer cette bévue s'y attendait juste
avant de donner la parole monsieur le
député vous avez 3 3 secondes
monsieur le ministre vo artifices de
communication n'y feront rien je renvoie
au rapport de la cour des comptes qui
est public est accablant ya le moins de
policiers sur le thème mais film plus
la parole et qu'un monsieur paul
christophe
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre chargé de l'industrie je
souhaite attirer votre attention sur la
situation fragilisée les industries
fortement dépendante du coût de
l'électricité
c'est le cas notamment de l'entreprise
aquanord à gravelines que j'ai rencontré
récemment ou de france ça lisons dans la
circonscription de mon collègue thomas
gars s'ils louent ces deux entreprises
se trouvant sur exposé face à l'envolée
du prix de l'énergie ces deux fleurons
économiques faute de rentabilité
pourrait demain être contraint d'arrêter
leur production comme le démontre la
fermeture récente de l' usine de zinc
nyrstar dans le nord c'est aussi une
question d'urgence pour les industries
hyper électro-intensives dit à choi ces
industries se caractérise par une
utilisation très importante de
l'électricité comme matière première qui
devient de fait le facteur prédominant
de leur compétitivité depuis le 1er
janvier 2022 elle se trouve doublement
fragilisé à la fois par l'augmentation
du prix de l'électricité et là par la
baisse du plafond de l'accès régulé de
l'électricité nucléaire historique dit à
rennes ainsi à titre d'exemple pour
l'entreprise aluminium dunkerque au sein
de ma circonscription premier producteur
européen d'aluminium primaire avec 285
mille tonnes de production annuelle est
une convention formation électrique de 4
térawattheures par an le déséquilibre
induit un traînerait un déficit annuel
insurmontable de plus de 200 millions
d'euros ce déficit estimé se basant
uniquement sur un tarif de 330 à 30
euros du mégawattheures là où il est
attendu à près de 600 euros du
mégawattheures en fin d'année cet
exemple permet d'illustrer l'urgence de
la situation pour une bonne partie de
notre industrie stratégique fortement
dépendante du coût de l'électricité
elle envoie également un message négatif
au moment où nous voulons décarbonés
notre industrie en la rendant moins
dépendantes des énergies fossiles aussi
madame la ministre quelles stratégies
proposez vous pour répondre à l'urgence
de la situation afin d'assurer la
pérennisation de ce tissu industriel
indispensable mais aujourd'hui menacé
enfin comment entendez vous assurer la
compétitivité énergétique à long terme
de notre industrie nécessaires pour
accompagner notre transition écologique
et la sauvegarde des emplois du secteur
d'activité
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
madame agnès pannier rina chez ministre
délégué chargé de l'industrie
mais dans quel état
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député paul christophe vous
le savez le gouvernement et notamment
bruno le maire barbara pompili et moi
même sommes pleinement mobilisés face à
la situation sans précédent que nous
traversons en matière de prix de
l'énergie alors cette situation elle est
totalement atypique puisque le prix de
l'électricité a été multipliée par cinq
je parle du prix l'électricité
évidemment sur le marché ce prix
l'électricité ce n'est pas celui que
payent les français puisque aujourd'hui
en 2021 les français n'ont pas vu ce
prix se traduire dans leurs factures
grâce aux mesures prises par le
gouvernement et c'est également vrai des
entreprises qui sont restés dans le
secteur d'y réguler ou qui avait
anticipé par des couvertures leur
fourniture en électricité il n'en
demeure pas moins il n'en demeure pas
moins que nous devons effectivement
prendre en compte cette situation et
faire en sorte d'accompagner les
industriels alors il faut le rappeler le
premier bouclier que nous avons c'est le
nucléaire c'est ce qui permet
aujourd'hui aux industriels français sur
près la moitié de leur facture de payer
leur électricité à 42 euros du
mégawattheures vous avez articuler les
chiffres sur le marché aujourd'hui et
les anticipations de certains experts
demain on voit bien les quarts
absolument majeur cela permet
aujourd'hui à des entreprises comme
aluminium dunkerque et rim et saint-jean
d'être parmi les derniers sites
d'aluminium actifs en europe je crois
que c'est important qu'on le conduise
souligner dans l'esprit également de
contrôler cette augmentation des prix de
l'électricité nous avons décidé en
octobre de de proposer au parlement un
amendement qui baissaient fortement la
fiscalité pour certains usagers très
intensive d'électricité et qui s'est
traduit par une base de 150 millions de
leurs factures b aujourd'hui la
situation légitime d'aller plus
nous travaillons dessus avec notamment
les acteurs juillet edf et dans l'est
je pense mais si
la parole est à madame pascale
fonctionnel personnes
n'ont à madame agnès style parlant
milétrie merci c'est involontaire madame
pilote tué conséquences merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale quel manque de
respect pour les enfants les parents et
tous les personnels enseignants la
veille de la rentrée scolaire monsieur
le ministre vous annoncer dans un
article payant
sans prévenir personne
l'instauration d'un nouveau protocole
sanitaire dans les écoles à coups de
multiplication de test à charge des
parents et le revirement de règles
d'isolement est la veille un dimanche à
16h pour le lendemain matin à 8 heures
de qui se moque t-on franchement quel
manque de réalisme et d'anticipation non
seulement les enfants vont encore subir
les frais de ces changements incessants
mais la pilule est surtout dur à avaler
pour les enseignants pour les directeurs
et les parents pris au dépourvu et
contraints de s'organiser dans l'urgence
quelques heures avant la rentrée au
moment même où de nouveaux profs et où
deux preuves nombreux professeurs sont
qu'à contacter ou asymptomatiques
qu'elle que le taux d'incidence est très
élevée chez les enfants alors même que
le nombre de tests a chuté pendant les
vacances et que les autotests gratuit
que vous aviez promis sont toujours
absents au sein des établissements
d'autres solutions étaient envisageables
pour éviter cette situation ubuesque la
journée d'hier a été chaotique mon
collègue de la somme grégory labille
signalait que selon le rectorat d'amiens
8 % des enseignants premier et second
degré étaient absents et 50 classes
fermées hier matin voici le résultat de
la méthode gouvernementale désormais
habituel de décidé de gouverner en
solitaire aussi monsieur le ministre je
vous demande combien de classes ont déjà
fermé en france en 24 heures pour cause
enfants professeur positif n'aurait-il
pas été plus de reporter la re la
rentrée au regard de l'évolution
épidémique et quand comptez vous équiper
les enseignants de masques ffp2 je
me disais dix questions nationales la
jeunesse et des sports monsieur blanc
caire
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés verts la députée a
nié style bien je sais que vous rédigez
votre question avant le début de la
séance mais c'est vrai que c'est
toujours un peu pennant de voir que des
réponses ont été apportées déjà la
question vous venez de poser vous n'en
tenez aucunement compte donc vous
répéter quelque chose dont vous savez
maintenant que c'est faux mais vous
préférez le dire plutôt que de tenir
compte de la réponse n'importe qui peut
vérifier ma réponse il y avait la foire
aux questions sur internet beaucoup plus
précise que l'article a donc eu une
communication interne précise d'une part
et une communication externe d'autre
part notamment pour les familles que ce
soit le dimanche après midi je vais
expliquer pourquoi les grandes lignes
ont été dites bien avant dès le mardi et
ensuite nous avons suivi un processus
qui était annoncée à l'avancé puisque
nous avons eu le l'avis du haut conseil
le 31 au soir je leur dis aussi ce qui a
été dit dimanche ne changeait rien au
lundi matin le lundi matin c'est les
règles que tout le monde connaissait
avant les vacances qui s'appliquait et
j'avais d'ailleurs préfigurer cela dans
mon intervention du mardi précédent donc
vous savez dans cette crise je vous dis
à vous comme je le dis au banc d'en face
avec lesquels vous êtes alliés dans ce
genre de circonstances pour créer des
polémiques dans ces circonstances il ya
ce qui est de mettre de l'huile sur le
feu et ceux qui travaillent que ce soit
difficile madame la députée personnes
dans 10 convient si vous voulez me faire
dire que la situation est difficile
oui si vous voulez me faire dire que le
mois de janvier est compliqué je vais
vous répondre oui la question c'est
maintenant de regarder les causes et les
manières de répondre aux difficultés
liées à ce variant alors vous me posez
une question j'y réponds elle était un
peu présente dans la question votre et
de la réponse d'ailleurs c'est le taux
d'absentéisme actuellement oui nous
craignons cela évidemment du fait du
variance est évident c'est même l'un des
problèmes principaux de ce mois de
janvier le chiffre que vous avez cités
pour la somme est assez représentatif de
ce qui se passe nationalement c'est à
dire hier dans la journée nous avions
entre 5 et 10 % d'absentéisme nous
sommes capables de faire cela avec nos
moyens de remplacement de faire face à
cela donc aujourd'hui nous gérons et
depuis hier matin les écoles de france
sont ouvertes c'est quand même le
premier des bienfaits et oui nous
assurons le remplacement autant que nous
le pouvons et nous sommes donc un des
pays mais réussissent au lyrisme trois
secondes madame t-il
merci il ya quand même combien de
classes fermées donc 50 en picardie et
mettez vous à la place des parents merci
madame la députée la parole est à madame
pascale fonctionnel personnes merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre lors
amplis et rachesky en charge des
retraites et de la santé au travail j'y
associe ma collègue violaine de courson
monsieur le ministre la semaine dernière
la presse nationale s'est fait l'écho
d'une caisse de retraite qui a demandé à
une infirmière le remboursement d'une
partie des salaires qu'elle avait
touchés lorsqu'elle était temporairement
venus aider ses anciens collègues de
l'ehpad les salaires versés par cet
ehpad lui ayant fait dépasser le plafond
du cumul emploi-retraite autorisé un
autre exemple une infirmière en retraite
des services d'urgence de la sarthe
participe activement la vaccination en
faisant cas de vacations par semaine
chaque vacation est de 4 heures à 24
euros de l'heure soit 96 euros par 4 par
vacation elle m'informe que sa
participation active à l'effort national
lui permet bien de rester sous le
plafond du cumul emploi retraite mais
que par contre elle change de tranche
fiscale pensez vous qu avec la
fulgurance de la cinquième vague et
l'augmentation exponentielle des cas
omicron nous puissions nous passer un
instant de ce personnel retraité qui est
venu en renfort sans faire le moindre
calcul la mobilisation de tous les
personnels soignants de notre pays
retraités inclus devient incontournable
me sens donc urgent de supprimer
temporairement le plafond du cumul
emploi retraite et de geler le
changement de tranches fiscales pour
tous et soignants engagées parallèlement
il devient indispensable de supprimer
temporairement également le délai de
carence qui empêche pendant six mois une
personne qui vient de prendre sa
retraite de retourner chez son dernier
employeur
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple pouvons nous adapter et ça et
fier ces règles dès maintenant pour ces
infirmières et infirmiers retraités dont
la solidarité et l'engagement sans
faille exprimés l'ont exprimons leur
notre reconnaissance en les gratifiant
tout simplement merci madame la députée
la parole est à monsieur laurent petit
razowski secrétaire d'état chargé des
retraites et de la santé au travail bon
allez merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée pascale fontenelle personnes
bon d'abord merci de faire référence à
toutes celles et tous ceux qui
contribuent encore aujourd'hui à la
stratégie vaccinale et à la lutte contre
la pandémie s'est directement l'objet de
votre question c'est vrai qu'il ya des
dispositions madame la députée qui est
vite on va dire quelles raisons
d'optimisation en fait d'avoir notamment
pour ceux qui sont partis en retraite
qui ne sont pas parties au moment du
taux plein de retourner chez leur ancien
employeur dans les six mois et
éventuellement ils peuvent eux aussi
subir d'ailleurs des abattements de
pension regard de rémunération
utiliserait perçu tout cela je les
traités jeu les traiter avec olivier
ferrand en son temps pour que justement
ce que vous avez décrit ne puisse pas
arrivé donc je pense que la question va
vous rassurer en la matière les mesures
qui ont été prises elles sont elles ont
été d'ailleurs précisé à l'article 3 de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale de 2022 et elle assure aux
professionnels de santé qui ont repris
une activité et c'est le cas de vos
exemples entre le 1er octobre 2020 le 31
décembre 2021 que les règles que nous
évoquer en matière de cumul emploi
retraite ne s'appliquerait pas tous les
professionnels de santé sont concernés
qu'ils soient par exemple médecins
pharmaciens infirmiers et c'est vrai
aussi d'ailleurs que l'on soit à
l'hôpital ou sur un dans un cabinet
libéral pour faire de la vaccination
aussi on centres de santé moi je peux
vous assurer que l'infirmière que vous
avez évoqué n'a pas de longs calculs à
faire en la matière il faut qu'elle
continue à s'investir dans la stratégie
vaccinale aux côtés de toutes celles et
de tous ceux qui contribuent à lutter
contre la pandémie et je voudrais vous
le dire aussi on aime la députée vous
aurais je pense ce soir l'occasion de
voter l'amendement 679 du projet de loi
renforçant les outils de gestion de
crise sanitaire et qui vaut 10 efira le
code de santé publique
de manière à ce que les dispositions que
je viens d'évoquer avec vous qui était
valable jusqu'au 31 décembre 2021 puis
s'étendre également pour l'année à venir
je vous remercie ma famille la parole
est à monsieur mansour kamardine
elle si le président est super mais mini
cher collègue monsieur le ministre de la
santé je fais partie des trop nombreux
français qui ont séjourné à l'hôpital
pour le coz decaux vide j'ai fait partie
des ces millions de français qui ont
suivi vos conseils puis vos objections
d'accepter l'inoculation dans le corps
d'un vaccin encore au stade expérimental
d'évaluation sur vos conseils c'est un
euphémisme le parlement a autorisé le
passage iter c'est ainsi que nous avons
toujours sur vos conseils rassurant
résultats mais l'injonction puis une
deuxième une troisième dans le seul
dessein de pouvoir rire de nos libertés
comme cela n'est pas suffisant malgré
vos affirmations définitives précédentes
vous proposer désormais de commuer le
pass sanitaire au pass vaccinale dans le
même temps vous vous apprêtez exigée
d'ici peu vous l'avez déjà envisagé
publiquement une quatrième dose puis
sans doute une cinquième pour que nous
puissions préserver nos libertés
animaux vous l'avez constaté je ne fais
pas partie des ces gaulois réfractaires
alors monsieur le ministre puisque il
est désormais admis que le chemin
vicinal emprunté ne conduira pas
l'immunité collective promise je vous
demande simplement au nom de la
transparence du débat démocratique
devant la représentation nationale
combien de doses ou à recevoir chaque
français autour de notre gratification
au profit du bilan de faveur
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de la santé et des
solidarités monsieur olivier vers en
jeu ça m'arrive monsieur débuté je reste
sans voix devant votre question
je reste sans voix devant la
responsabilité que vous prenez comme
parlementaire du groupe l'est
républicain
en ayant des affirmations comme celle
que vous venez de tenir je sens
d'ailleurs pardonnez moi de décrire mais
que vous êtes un peu isolé dans votre
groupe je le souhaite ardemment sur
cette question là mais ce député
parler d'inoculation d'un vaccin
expérimental
alors qu' il ya des milliards d'humains
qui ont été vaccinés avec le vaccin
sauvent des vies et que nous nous
battons collectivement pour permettre
aux français de se protéger
je n'ai pas d'autre réponse à vous faire
monsieur le député vous aurez compris
mon désarroi
merci monsieur le député vous les prêts
déjà le désarroi et pour lever seul
ministre parce que encore une fois plus
vous nous proposer de nouvelles ci n'est
plus notre action mais plus nous
vaccinons plus encore vous revenez en
disant c'est pas suffisant il faut qu'on
le fasse couiner voilà le désarroi dans
lequel nous nous trouvons
merci monsieur les buts et
la parole et à monsieur stéphane peu
merci merci monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de la santé et des solidarités
nous avons appris hier que la direction
de l'hôpital delafontaine à saint-denis
était contrainte de fermer jusqu'à
nouvel ordre faute de personnel le
nombre suffisant le service d'urgences
pédiatriques cette décision d'une
extrême gravité est d'abord source
d'angoissé pour les parents nombreux qui
craignent désormais ne plus pouvoir
compter sur ce service essentiel pour
leurs enfants elle en dit plus que bien
des discours sur l'état déplorable de
l'hôpital public dans notre pays sur le
manque de moyens et l'épuisement des
soignants dans ce contexte
d'incertitudes et d'insécurité
sanitaires comment comprendre votre
décision d'instaurer à compter du 1er
janvier un forfait de 20 euros à la
charge des patients reçus en urgence et
qui ne feront pas l'objet d'une
hospitalisation
sous couvert de simplification il s'agit
en réalité de faire payer aux patients
les carences de la médecine de ville
monsieur le ministre aller aux urgences
n'est pas un choix mais bien souvent la
seule option qui s'offre aux assurés
sociaux quand on sait par exemple que
dans mon département mais c'est dans le
cas de bien d'autres mais dans mon
département de la seine saint denis plus
de 30 % des assurés sociaux ne dispose
pas de médecin traitant dans derrière
cette mesure comptable qui vise à
dissuader la fréquentation des urgences
il s'agit en fait
un changement de paradigme que vous
opérez nous étions fiers en france que
la carte vitale soit le seul sésame des
urgences faudra-t-il désormais y ajouter
la carte bleue comme aux états unis
monsieur le ministre cette mesure ne
fait qu'alimenter l'angoissent d'une
société qui a besoin au contraire d'être
rassuré ce n'est pas dans ce sens qu'il
faut agir pour réparer l'hôpital public
vous qui pète prétendez dans votre carte
de voeux je vous cite être fidèle à
l'ambition des pères fondateurs de la
sécurité sociale allez-vous en fidea a
eu renoncé à 7 merci monsieur le député
la parole est à monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités et la santé
[Applaudissements]
monsieur stéphane que je suis à peu près
certain que deux-tiers présent dans les
débats du plfss qui où la représentation
nationale a voté cette mesure de
demander d'ailleurs par les services
d'urgence par la fédération hospitalière
de france qui en aucun cas un reste à
charge pour les patients mais une mesure
de simplification
vous aviez auparavant reste à charge
moyen de 25,28 euros après un passage
aux urgences vous recevrez une facture
quelques jours ou quelques semaines plus
tard le plus souvent qu'il vous avec une
illusion de la gratuité des soins
lorsque vous arrivez aux urgences
c'était des sommes colossales pour
recouvrer d'ailleurs cette ceux du de la
part des hôpitaux qui nous ont demandé à
la place d'harmoniser d'unifier de faire
en sorte qu'il y ait un reste à charge
qu'ils soient moins importants
d'ailleurs 19 euros un peu moins 19
euros au lieu des 25 et quelques euros
donc c'est plutôt un progrès social mais
j'entends que maintenant quand on paye -
eh bien c'est une régression sociale
c'est votre choix mais pas vous
apprendre les mathématiques et encore
une fois une mesure vraiment
simplification qui était plébiscité par
tout le monde vous pourrez autant que
vous le souhaiterez monsieur le député
faire croire que nous visons à casser
l'hôpital ou à casser la protection
sociale les chiffres sont têtus et il
nous donne raison 30 milliards de plus
pour l'hôpital cette année un budget de
la sécurité sociale qui est en hausse
comme il ne l'avait pas été depuis
quinze ans une progression là par
l'assurance maladie qui remontait à 90
+2 81% prise en charge des soins une
télé médecine à 100% une vaccination à
100% des tests à 100% chercher ailleurs
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est un monsieur fabien goûte
aux femmes
attendez on va vous donner le micro
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre déléguée chargée de la
mémoire et des anciens combattants
madame la ministre alors que notre
assemblée a adopté le 18 novembre
dernier le projet de loi portant
reconnaissance de la nation et
réparation des préjudices subis par les
harkis du fait des conditions de leur
accueil sur le territoire français que
le sénat examinera en séance publique le
25 janvier prochain la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme a été saisi par
trois enfants de harkis et ont vécu dans
le camp de bias dans le lot-et-garonne
afin d'obtenir réparation des préjudices
subis en raison des conditions d'accueil
de leur famille à la fin de la guerre
d'algérie
courant septembre la cour adressé au
gouvernement à courrier dont les
réponses sont attendues fin février
les requérants madame la ministre a
reproché au gouvernement l'adoption à
venir du projet de loi en ce qu'il
empêcherait la juste réparation de leur
préjudice
il me semble pourtant que notre majorité
a depuis plus de près de 5 en fait bien
davantage que toutes les précédentes en
faveur de la reconnaissance des
souffrances et des traitements indignes
subi par ces combattants qui avaient
choisi la france l'aurait son texte
législatif que nous avons adoptées dans
cet hémicycle absolument nécessaire au
regard de notre histoire nationale vise
selon les mots mêmes du président de la
république à inscrire dans le marbre de
nos lois la reconnaissance et la
réparation à l'égard des harkis
aussi madame la ministre pouvez vous
nous rappeler le contexte qui a prévalu
à ce projet de loi ainsi que les
différentes étapes par lesquelles les
harkis ont été associées aux mesures
qu'il contient je vous remercie
madame la ministre déléguée chargée de
la mémoire et des anciens combattants
madame geneviève darrieussecq
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
fabien une goutte farde alors vous le
savez il n'appartient pas au
gouvernement de présenter les procédures
judiciaires en cours et je ne le ferai
donc pas je rappellerai simplement que
transmission d'un questionnaire par les
services de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme aux services
juridiques nationaux est normal et
usuels ça s'inscrit dans le cadre d'un
dialogue entre la cour avec les états
sur les affaires en cours le
questionnaire en question a été transmis
par la cour le 27 septembre dernier au
gouvernement français alors vous avez
bien compris que notre action pour les
harkis et celle qui est voulu par le
président de la république est le date
elle du mois en fin de l'année 2017
puisque défunt la fin de l'année 2010
est celle mis en place une commission la
commission sow qui a établi un rapport
très documenté à partir de ce rapport
nous avons mis en oeuvre ce fonds de
solidarité pour les enfants de harkis
nous avons mis en oeuvre une
augmentation de l'allocation de
reconnaissance pour les harkis
combattons nous avons développé de très
nombreux sujets mémorielle dès le mois
de mai 2021 le président de la
république a lancé une concertation avec
les représentants des harkis le 20
septembre dernier il a eu un discours
fort à leur adresse reconnaissant les
fautes de la république à leur encontre
et demandant pardon il s'est engagé à
mettre en oeuvre une loi de
reconnaissance et de réparation que vous
avez voté ici le 18 novembre et la loi
bah vous l'avez dit passe bien sûr au
sénat dans quelques semaines et enfin
depuis le 1er janvier 2022 nous avons
augmenté la reconnaissance pour les
harkis combattants puisque leur
allocation de reconnaissance a été
multiplié par 2 passant à 8350 euros par
an donc très simplement dire que
l'action vis-à-vis des harkis elle a
duré pendant tout notre mandat elle a
été en continuité de ce qui a été fait
par les autres merci gouvernement mais
elle a été très bonne et elle sera très
complet film à la ministre
la parole est à madame michèle victory
merci merci président
ma question s'adresse pour la cinquième
fois au ministre de l'éducation
nationale s'est sûrement dire là tout
notre inquiétude sur ces questions est
oui la question était préparée comme le
sont réponse monsieur le ministre c'est
la règle du jeu c'est donc avec une
certaine consternation que les
personnels éducatifs ont découvert votre
protocole sanitaire la veille de la
rentrée ou tout au moins des échos
qu'ils en ont tu puisses que vous avez
jugé préférable d'informer la presse
payante avant les enseignants cela a été
rappelé par tous les groupes les
dispositions annoncées ne reprennent
bien sûr aucune des demandes formulées
par les principaux concernés qui était
le report de la rentrée une campagne
vaccinale en faveur des enseignants la
distribution de masques ffp2 les tests
massif au sein des écoles car nous
sommes peut-être les champions des tests
mais nous ne sont pas les champions de
l'accompagnement des familles et de ce
casque est épouvantable pour les
familles le directeur d'école et de la
gêne et la généralisation des capteurs
de co2 à la place vous proposer la
distribution d'autotest les pharmacies
s'inquiète pourtant la saturation de
leurs officines et des risques de bonne
utilisation et de fiabilité et le
recours aux enseignants en retraite pour
remplacer au pied levé les professeurs
malades nous attendons donc de voir on
se demande pourtant comment des
personnes à risque si elles ne sont pas
elles mêmes contaminées ou cas contacts
vont pouvoir assurer la continuité
pédagogique que nous voulons tous et
toutes ici car avec un taux d'incidence
record frôlant les 800 cas pour 100000
des 6-17 ans nous nous interrogeons
sérieusement sur la possibilité même
d'assurer les enseignements ainsi selon
l'outil kovy tracker 680 personnes par
exemple sont réunis en ardèche où le
taux d'incidence et 2434 soit la taille
d'un gros collège le risque de
contamination est de 100% monsieur le
ministre où est donc la logique le
variant au micro on ne provoque pas
l'absentéisme des personnels et les mots
ont un sens mais bien l'incapacité de
ces derniers a enseigné à encadrer a
participé au bon déroulement de la vue
des écoles cérémonie semaine a débuté
chez obligé de couper la parole
alors monsieur
monsieur lancker ministre de l'éducation
nationale merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée michèle vittori non à la
députée ma réponse n'est pas écrite à
l'avancé j'ai trop de respect pour vous
pour ne pas d'abord écouter pour
répondre quelque chose d'adapter et donc
je pense que peut-être un respect
réciproque serait d'avoir écouté mes
réponses et de faire évoluer votre
question en fonction puisque j'ai déjà
répondu en effet quatre fois à la
question est donc je le répète je le
répète répéter un mensonge n'en fait pas
une vérité
dimanche dernier les informations ont
été données évidemment gratuitement et
d'ailleurs de manière beaucoup plus
précise en communication interne en même
temps qu'elle était donnée en
communication externe pour pour les
familles c'est la réalité n'importe qui
peut le vérifier et donc je sais qu'on a
mis à chaque fois créé une polémique on
a trouvé celle ci ensuite j'ai explique
pourquoi c'est la veille que certaines
précisions peuvent être donnés je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure on va essayer d'en
faire une polémique les grandes lignes
de la rentrée était exposé auparavant et
surtout lundi matin des choses n'étaient
pas différentes dans ce qu'il y avait à
faire de ce que de ce qui se passait
avant l'entrée notre politique a permis
d'ajuster en permanence le protocole en
réalité c'est comme ça que nous avons
fait une évolution en décembre dernier
qui a multiplié par plus de six le
nombre de tests réalisés sur les enfants
la politique de test de la france nous
honore le mini de la santé l'a rappelé
par le nombre de tests effectués ça
concerne les enfants désormais en effet
ça permet d'endiguer ce la deuxième
réussite française collective le fait
que nous sommes un des pays qui a le
plus d'élèves de 12 à 17 ans vacciné
plus de 80% c'est un des grands facteurs
de protection de l'enseignement
secondaire depuis le début de la
distribution des masques en tant que
responsabilité de l'état employeur se
passe aussi depuis le début d'une
manière logistiquement très forte qui a
soixante mille points quand lesquels
nous alimenter en permanence le nombre
de masques alors oui il ya une politique
de masse oui il ya une politique de test
vous me parlez des capteurs de co2 je
rappelle que c'est une compétence des
collectivités locales je suis surpris
par certaines mairies de votre couleur
politique qui n'en n'ont toujours pas
acheté il y à un fonds d'état pour les
soutenir
si elles ont ainsi elles ont un problème
ne faisons pas une polémique sans merci
monsieur le ministre essayons merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame béatrice taurine
je remercie monsieur le président donc
ma question s'adresse à monsieur
ministre de l'économie 'l'indice du cac
40 a clôturé l'année 2009 21 ans - sans
une augmentation de près de 30% des
passants et de loin son précédent record
datant de septembre 2000 il est donc à
son plus haut niveau depuis 21 ans et ce
en pleine pandémie alors que dans le
pays la précarité des emplois et le
chômage la pauvreté augmente que
l'économie est sous perfusion que les
petites et moyennes entreprises se sont
serré la ceinture
et d'ailleurs selon un sondage de leur
confédération un tiers déclarent que
leur entreprise est menacée
pendant ce temps-là certain nombre d
entreprises bénéficiant des aides de
l'étang ont déversé des dividendes à
leurs actionnaires
les 120 entreprises françaises les plus
importantes ont versé 51 milliards de
dividendes de l'an dernier en même temps
ces entreprises ont annoncé la
suppression de plus de 60000 postes dans
le monde depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire dont près de la moitié en
france
si on prend l'exemple de sanofi le
groupe a touché 1 milliard 500 millions
d'euros le crédit d'impôt recherche
en dix ans le groupe a versé 4 milliards
de dividendes en 2020 et à supprimer
dans le même temps me le poste dont 400
dans la branche recherche et
développement en plein temps dès midi on
attend de voir ce qu'ils verseront pour
l'année 2000 21 est donc bienvenue dans
le monde extraordinaire de la république
en marche où les actionnaires voient
leurs profits augmenter de 10 milliards
alors de plusieurs milliards alors que
10 milliards 10 millions de citoyennes
et de citoyens sur vivent sous le seuil
de pauvreté 50 milliards de bénéfices
pour les actionnaires 10 milliards de
pauvres monsieur le ministre
qu'attendez vous pour faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait plus de licenciements dans
ces entreprises qui distribuent des
dividendes
qu'attendez vous pour cautionner les de
même la députée la parole est à madame
agnès pannier rynnas ministre délégué
chargé de l'industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
taurine le fait que les résultats des
grandes entreprises françaises soit bon
et le signe que l'économie française se
porte bien malgré la crise et je crois
que nous devrions tous nous en réjouir
bruno le maire l'a indiqué ce matin nous
terminons l'année avec le taux de
croissance le plus élevé depuis 50 ans
il nous démarrons l'année avec un acquis
de croissance qui nous permet de
confirmer notre prévision de croissance
à 4% en 2022 cette reprise est la plus
forte en europe et elle bénéficie et
c'est ça qui est important à tous les
français
car quels sont les chiffres olivier
dussopt peut mentionner à l'instant une
baisse de 10 % des bénéficiaires du rsa
c'est ça efficacement traiter les
questions de pauvreté eu un taux
d'emploi le plus élevé depuis plus de 40
ans un taux d'emploi des jeunes qui a
longtemps été notre difficulté le plus
élevé depuis 40 ans également cette
reprise elle se double d'une
amélioration de la rémunération des gens
qui travaillent grâce aux réformes qui
ont été mises en place depuis 2010 est
et je veux rappeler l'augmentation de la
prime d'activité qui permet aux
personnes rémunérées au smic être
rémunéré à 1490 euros net par mois je
veux rappeler la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires je veux rappeler
la baisse des cotisations pardon j'ai
plus de voix employés au niveau du smic
enfin un chiffre parce qu'à un moment il
faut tordre le cou aux préjugés
contrairement à ce que vous affirmez les
dividendes versés en 2008 s'est élevé à
54 milliards d'euros en 2007 à 57
milliards d'euros et donc en 2020 ils
sont inférieurs à ces deux années merci
beau merci
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
notre séance s'est terminée sur le
pommeau unis je salue les béarnais
d'abord et puis je suspends je suspends
notre séance avant que leur vie ne soit
reprise par le vice-président le fur